what were you just teaching me about
mouth breathing and how it changes the
shape of the face now so I arrived
carrying a copy of the book Jaws a
hidden epidemic this is not Jaws the
shark uh this book was written by my
colleagues at Stanford sandre Khan and
Paul Erick and it has an introduction by
Jared Diamond who won aiter for gun
storms and steel and a forward by the
great Robert spolski also a colleague of
mine at Stanford so four Heavy Hitters
on this book just to credential it first
um this book centers around a couple of
Core Concepts but the first being that
people and in particular children who
overuse mouth breathing as opposed to
nasal
breathing have changes in the structure
of the face that well to be quite direct
makes them far more unattractive than if
they were to mouth breathe it also
discusses the chewing of Foods as
essential to mouth and face development
Sandra KH is an expert in cranial
facial function and structure um and the
fact that if your parents and you did
things right you should be able to place
your your entire tongue on the roof of
your mouth with your mouth closed now I
can't do that okay so when you're with
teeth closed tongue in the roof of your
mouth I can but I still feel the back of
my teeth a bit um so yeah okay um but
the so that's the second point that we
want to chew chewing Foods is essential
to tooth and mouth and face development
um these days many children slurp their
food many adults slurp their Foods um
many adults are eating like babies and
of course babies before they develop
their mature teeth and even when they
before they get all over their teeth in
need to obviously breast milk and um you
know pudding like Foods okay but so
that's the second point so nasal
breathing good mouth breathing bad for
cranial facial development chewing hard
Foods chewing a lot on both sides of the
mouth great for cranial facial
development oral development tooth
development and tooth Health which by
the way are correlated with a number of
other things like cardiovascular health
and metabolic Health very interesting
links there and then the third point is
that uh the the book argues that the
entire field of orthodontia things like
um braces things like headgear things
like retainers are the byproduct of poor
um breathing and let's just say uh overc
consumption of soft foods in place of
hard Foods uh behavior and so there's
this guy who's from your side of the
pond Mew the Mew method um of restoring
normal crano facial development the book
is choca block full of impressive photos
of before and afters impressive because
in some cases you'll see kids that were
um mouth breathers or were eating a lot
of soft foods and then they recovered
their behavior so to speak and became
nose breathers of course we have to
mouth breathe when we're exercising
really hard or when we're eating or
speaking we're going to mouth breathe
but at rest we should nasal breathe is
the argument and that greatly improves
cranofacial
um Aesthetics and the good news is this
stuff is modifiable across the lifespan
and um and so the book isn't arguing for
anyone to purchase anything you need a
jawser sizer I'm saying that explicitly
because they took clips of me talking
about this and and and productized it
and I had nothing to do with that so
hopefully you'll keep this in the
episode and they even admitted they were
breaking the law and he said we don't
care we're going to continue to do it so
sales to sales man yeah but now those
those you know to to the credit of of um
products for um exercising the jaw sure
there are muscles of the jaw that can CH
the aesthetic but using food to do that
eat tough food is if you don't have a
sufficiently tough diet I guess you
could replace it but it's explain to me
the mechanics of how the difference in
whether you breathe through your nose or
breathe through your mouth changes the
shape of your face and head yeah well
and it goes beyond that if you breathe
through your mouth as opposed to your
nose the first of all you bring in less
oxygen than you would so you're you're
limiting you're effectively putting
yourself into a state of apnea right
which is bad during sleep and guess what
it's bad during waking States also
you're getting less oxygen to your brain
bad the sinuses you know we hear are my
sinuses are clogged or my the sinuses
wish I had brought a skull with with me
because one of the most impressive
things about a skull human skull being
no exception is that the sinuses are
literally these little uh tubes or
channels through which fluid and air can
move and the sinuses even though they
are essentially the created by the
fissures between different bones so like
there're this two two or three different
bones that are interdigitated and create
these tunnels they're actually Fair
plastic in the sense that they can be
modified in terms of their shape and and
so people will say well I have a
deviated septum guess what you should
try and emphasize breathing through both
nostrils as a in order to UND deviate
your septum now if someone has a broken
nose or something that's really
structurally abnormal they may need
corrective surgery but purely through n
deliberate nasal breathing so it could
be mouth taping at night but also just
deliberately nasal breathing during most
of your cardiovascular training unless
you need to really you know hit the gas
in which case mouth breathe is going to
help dilate the sinuses and lead to
better air flow which makes nasal
breathing easier the other thing is that
nasal breathing we know um well first of
all there's a nasal microbiome there's
also an oral microbiome but the nasal
microbiome is particularly well suited
to um scrub or capture and destroy
viruses bacteria and even some fungal
infections so in other words when you're
breathing in through your mouth you're
more susceptible to infections this is
important heading into winter as well um
so there are a number of I mean we could
talk about this for hours but the point
is nasal breathe when you can um kids
especially but adults as well chewing
foods that require you know eating foods
that require some chewing and really
working at it and chewing away um they
have some impressive images in this uh
book of kids that were twins that were
raised separately one by a group that
eats a lot of um let's just say tougher
foods that require chewing versus one
that's slurping their food and I mean
one kid is literally incredibly
attractive perfect denature with no
orthodonture or D or you know regular
dentistry in the other kid is teeth is
like
they have the like the horsey smile even
though they've got the same genetic
predisposition right it's not a perfect
experiment because there are other
factors as well and you know none of
this is um the For Better or Worse none
of this is really amenable to kind of in
laboratory type stuff um so as these are
naturally occurring experiments as we
say um there are also some very
impressive images in the book or we
could say depressing of kids that were
pretty attractive as kids and then there
there's an example of a kid who got a
pet hamster he was allergic to the
hamster he switch as a consequence he
becomes a mouth breather and then that
the characteristic um change in the face
when one over does mouth breathing is
that the chin start to move back
recesses toward the um toward the neck
and that the rest of the face go out but
also the eyes become droopy um and this
but as you say why would the eyes be
affected it's not just musculature
what's happening is there's um less use
of literally the the sinuses in the
upper towards the upper mandible and up
towards the eyes because if you ever had
a sinus infection it's painful up here
in your forehead and around the eyes so
again it's pretty straightforward no
products required chew chew your food
well chew on both sides of your mouth um
especially if you're a young person but
even if you're not um be a nasal
breather really chew at your food try
and this probably also has benefits in
terms of limiting um unessential or low
low nutrient density calories you know
slurping your food all the time I mean I
love drink your calories man I love a
good Greek yogurt you know but um but
drinking an excess of calories is
probably not good and and eat like an
adult I would say you know one of the
things is I I don't know like to me
growing up snack food was something that
kids um indulged in you know on once you
hit 18 or so you know eat like an adult
like I'm still wait I'm still waiting to
to learn that lesson you mentioned
spolski that I had him on the show
recently yeah what do you think most
people misunderstand about stress
obviously he's contributed an awful lot
to this and you've thought about this
too yeah what do you think people don't
understand fully about stress yeah the
findings that I think are overlooked
tremendously are the following
experiment um there's an experiment in
animals where a rat is given the
opportunity to run on a treadmill and
rats and and rodents of all kind love
kinds love running on treadmills you
know there these interesting um we'll
see who catches this fly first yeah I'm
ready man the uh I think um you know
there's even a study from hoppy
hofstra's Lab at at Harvard that showed
that if you put a Wheels running Wheels
in fields that rodents will run there in
the middle of the night and run on them
that's how insanely uh obsessed with
running they're just entic they want to
go there's something rewarding about it
for them but in any event it lowers
their blood pressure it leads to Inc
improvements in a number of metrics that
you expect and you see the same thing in
humans right who run on a treadmill or
run Outdoors or Swim cardiovascular
exercise okay well um spolski um and I
love to talk about a an experiment where
they took two different cages with
animals one is running voluntarily
but then that running wheel is Tethered
to a running wheel in another cage that
encloses an animal forces it to run
every time the other one runs so forced
exercise versus voluntary exercise and
the takeaway is very straightforward
voluntary exercise leads to all sorts of
improvements in health metrics resting
heart rate blood pressure blood glucose
um resting blood glucose Etc waking
blood glucose um the animal that's
forced to exercise you see the opposite
right so it's not exercise per se it's
something about being forced to exercise
is causes um decrements in a number of
Health metrics and you see the same
thing in humans so what's Wild is my
colleague Dr Ali Crum Department of
psychology at Stanford um has done these
beautiful experiments on mindset and
belief these are not Placebo effects and
what she's shown in in a just absolutely
spectacular way is that if people watch
a short video about all the ways in
which stress can really diminish your
health well then indeed stress
diminishes their health whereas if a
separate group watch is an a factual
also five minute also factual tutorial
on all the ways that stress can enhance
performance by harnessing your ability
to focus memory formation Etc all of
which is true that's indeed what you see
can I give you my favorite one that I
learned about over the last year yes so
the Boston Marathon
bombing uh
2012 about 10 years ago 2016 maybe
anyway Boston Marathon bombing a study
was done comparing people who had been
at the actual Marathon while the bomb
had gone off and people who had watched
90 minutes or more of news coverage
about it and the people who watch 90
minutes or more of news coverage about
it showed a greater stress response than
the people who' literally lived through
it interesting interesting yeah
the the um the the mindset and belief
effects are are absolutely extraordinary
and and very real right I mean I think
you know um recently I've been reading
and researching a lot about and did a
podcast on tenacity and willpower and um
there was this idea early on from balme
and colleagues that willpower is a
limited resource some of ego depletion
ego depletion um it was controversial um
they showed that you know replenishing
glucose in between hard tasks could
restore willpower they showed that uh
was it juries or judges that were low in
blood glucose were more likely to give
harsher sentences stuff like this yeah
it it sort of wicked out to a number of
naturalistic situ situations and it made
good sense and then my colleague Carol
DW also in the psychology department at
Stanford um most famously known for her
work on mind growth mindset did an
experiment in which they um essentially
asked whether or not tenacity and
willpower are limited in terms of being
a some sort of resource and also whether
or not it was somehow linked to glucose
availability fuel uh in the brain and
body and found that if people thought or
were told that mine that uh excuse me
willpower was a limited resource that's
indeed what they observed experimentally
but that if they were taught or were
told that willpower is unlimited and and
divorced from glucose levels well then
that's exactly what you saw you're
saying that learning about ego depletion
and believing that willpower is a
limited resource is an information
Hazard that is self-fulfilling uh
potentially now now now now bow Meister
you know showed um himself to be you
know pretty determined um when and
countered the the uh the dck counter by
showing that if indeed if there's a hard
task followed by a hard task then your
beliefs about willpower um Can impact
your performance on the second task so D
the AKA D is right but that if you have
a hard task hard task and then another
hard task so back to back to back tasks
or more which is a lot of what life is
like well then it seems that the W that
the willpower is a limited resource and
glucose supporting will will power
Theory holds up a bit better what have
you come to believe about the difference
between willpower and motivation and
discipline how how do kind of all of
these fit together in your mind yeah so
Willow and tenacity um are related to
motivation but they're not quite the
same I think we should think of U
motivation as a um as the verb state
that moves us from um let's just say
apathy to tenacity okay so it's it's
it's the verb function that moves us
along that Continuum a apathy at one end
U tenacity and willpower strong um
exertion of willpower at the other end
um one of the most interesting
structures in the entire nervous system
is one that gets very little coverage
unfortunately um in fact most
neuroscientists aren't aware of what its
function is and it's called the amcc
which is the anterior mid singulate
cortex you have one on each side of the
brain the name isn't really important
but we want to you know to to the credit
of the of the structure we should name
it the AMC
the amcc receives inputs from a lot of
interesting brain areas related to
reward related to autonomic function so
how alert or sleepy we are to prediction
to prediction error it's a hub for many
many inputs and outputs hormone systems
Etc beautiful experiments done by my
colleague Joe parvy at Stanford have
shown that if you stimulate this brain
area tiny little brain area in a human
they immediately feel as if some
challenge is impending and they're going
to meet that challenge it's a forward
Center of mass against challenge
response this has been seen in
independent subjects they do controls
where they then tell them they're
stimulating but they're not actually
stimulating and they're like I don't
feel anything you can turn on and off
tenacity and willpower so there's
literally a hub for this now here's
where it gets really interesting I'm
going to list off a bunch of
peer-reviewed published results in Rapid
sequence and I'm happy to uh point out
the the um substantiation for this or
the references okay individuals that are
dieting or resisting some sort of
tempting behavior and are successful in
doing that the size and activity in
their amcc goes up over time and the
structure gets bigger dieters who
fail flat or downward trajectory of the
size and activation of the
amcc this can be taken too far
individuals with anorexia nervosa the
most deadly of all psychiatric disorders
where a dep self-deprivation of food
activates excessive reward there's this
kind of loop of reward their AMC's are
sign significantly greater size than
others so there's you know this can be
taken too
far
superagers which is a bit of a misnomer
because these individuals are people who
maintain healthy cognitive function
similar to people in their 20s and 30s
into their 70s 80s and 90s their amcc
maintains or increases in size into
their later years typical agers the size
of we always hear that you lose brain
mass ac across your lifespan well most
of it is from the amcc and beautifully
and this is two of my favorite results
that really bring this around to a
protocol or a takeaway if people are
given an easy task the amcc isn't
activated if they're given a hard task
in particular a hard task physical or
cognitive that they really don't want to
do the amcc levels of activity go
through the roof and here's what's
really cool they gave aging let's you
know people age 60 to 79 the task of
adding three hours extra per week of
cardiovascular exercise now that's a lot
right three one hour they call them
aerobic classes but getting their heart
rate up to about 65 70% of of Maximum so
it's getting into like Zone 3ish area
yeah people can look up zone three but
you nailed it zone three the size of
their amcc increased across that
six-month protocol and offset the normal
age related decline in this in this
sprain area in terms of its
size the theory that's starting to
emerge is that the amcc isn't just about
tenacity and willpower to push through
hard things that it may actually be
related to one's will to live one's will
to continue living and I think this is
these are some of the most important
results by the way I didn't participate
in any of the research that I just
described I spent a lot of time with
that literature but I think it's so
important I mean we hear about the
amydala the hippocampus the prefrontal
cortex all of very important brain
structures but um if nothing else
hopefully this conversation put the amcc
on the map the one that literally could
create your will to live is the one
that's being overlooked a little bit and
and it can be and what's interesting
about this structure is that it's
involved in generating tenacity and
willpower for all things not just for
one situation and what's really
wonderful I think about the the research
literature on this is It's So Clear what
we need to do we need to do th let's say
like me you you're a person who enjoys
weightlifting and you love running I
love those two activities well guess
what those activities even if they're
hard like a hard run that I'm really
enjoying or some hard sets in the gym
not going to increase the size or
activity of the amcc people love to over
romanticize the utility of those final
two reps sure okay pushing to failure
great you know running hard till your
lungs burn great but if you enjoy that
you're not increasing your amount of
tenacity and willpower at least
according to the research data what's
going to do it is doing something what I
call Micro sucks or macro sucks you know
and so micro sucks could be all the
little things that you don't want during
to do during the day macro sucks could
be the larger things but of course you
don't want to do things that are going
to damage you psychologically or
physically of of course of course but
everyone I believe would benefit from um
picking a few micro sucks what what are
some of your micro sucks or macro sucks
that you could sprinkle throughout the
day okay so on a household maintenance
level um you know I I maintain a very
clean home I I I'm constantly throwing
things away as well but there are a few
things like once I exceed a certain
number of dishes in the sink it becomes
this okay I'll I'll load the dishwasher
later type thing like a micro suck for
me would be like especially if
something's been in there for a while
and it's kind of gross and you got to
like work through it and of course I try
and put each dish away as as I you know
dirty them up but um so little things
the things like that the I really don't
want to deal with that right now that's
the kind of thing those harder tasks
where you have to breach some barrier
some resistance to put it into you know
Steven pressfield language or um our
friend David goggin right you know this
idea that one has to callous the mind I
mean it David said that right he's
probably got an hypertrophied amcc
that's bigger than most people
probably and and the the beauty of
having a a an amcc that's highly you
know available for Activation is that
you know through the micro and the macro
sucks of the day you you have this thing
it's like an engine that you can devote
to other things so then you can devote
the amcc to other endeavors I have this
thing I called email anxiety and it's
when my unread inbox reaches three
figures or more and that's when it just
it kind of follows me around like a
poltergeist throughout the day and that
absolutely for me that's probably a
macro suck you know to get through that
it's probably 3 to four hours a lot of
it scheduling when's this guest coming
on I need to speak to this partner we
got blah blah blah um so yeah I feel
that um what else it's subjective right
I mean what's a what sucks is sub might
live emails yeah someone might and and I
think that um you know you've talked a
lot on your show with various guests
about you know when we're in too much
comfort uh are we're not meeting our
goals I love deadlines for that reason
um I I love deadlines I love pressure I
think I think Parkinson's lore is as
close to a thermodynamic of productivity
as we can get do you know what I mean
like when you have a deadline you will
meet it right if you do not have a
deadline you will Manana Manana until
forever that's right and some people I
think um pre-load the deadline by
procrastinating and then that's what you
know gets their activation energy to a
level where they can they can engage so
I've started thinking about this a lot
lately you know I love running but it's
interesting I I like to finish it my
driveway and I live on a hill and um
actually this morning I was out for a
run and the gate at the end of the Colac
is my sort of designated stop point so
it actually sucked to do the last you
know 20 meters um this morning so there
I probably got a little bit of amcc
activation because everything was the
number of negotiations I went through
when I turned up my street at the end of
this run whether or not I was going to
run this extra 20 mters was ridiculous I
mean the human brain you know struggling
to not do this extra 20 MERS it was so
silly so it's got to it's got to hurt a
little bit again you don't want to
damage yourself but I think in the
context of um for instance cognitive
learning getting to the point where you
finish something and then forcing
yourself to do one little extra bit
there at the end so you know I I I'm not
looking for any credit for it but I want
to be very clear that the scientific
literature doesn't call these things
micros sucks I call them micros sucks um
and I S put that out there just to make
it um clear as to what we're refering do
you know Nick be I don't in Austin he's
a athlete and supp y yeah yeah yeah like
a hybrid athlete a larger guy but he
runs really fast does bodybuilding shows
does powerlifting also runs to be clear
I know that large guys run fast but um
typically they don't run uh fast for 20
miles correct and he does that's
accurate um he his little uh catchphrase
is go one more and it's interesting what
you're saying here is it's not just
about the completion of the thing that
you're doing because a lot of the time
the thing that you choose to do even the
thing that's difficult is done under
your own valtion mhm don't get me wrong
if you do a difficult crossfit workout
Fran whatever 2159 of thrusters and
pull-ups it is a it's hell right there's
literally a name for what your throat
feels like once you finish called Fran
cof that people get from having taken
their heart rate as high as spasming
of um that taste of metal in the back of
your throat but what what people are
doing there although they're doing
something that's difficult it's like
volitionally difficult and it's within
their domain of enjoyment and what
you're saying here is that we're we're
looking to just push ourselves a little
bit past that it's like an unnecessary
amount of Challenge and I think that go
one more makes quite a nice uh reminder
for us with the micro sucker the macro
suck let's push ourselves just a little
bit beyond where we would have got our
sense of satisfaction because presumably
you get the dopamine I've completed the
task [__] yeah and then it's like and
then I do just that tiny little bit more
to to bring in other news this episode
is brought to you by marrick health I
wanted to get my blood work done here in
America I'd been told by people like Dr
hubman that it's important for me to do
to work out what's going on inside of my
body but I didn't know where to go after
a ton of research I found out that Mar
health is the best and most
comprehensive when I started working
with them my testosterone was $495 which
is low normal not where I wanted it to
be now 6 months later it is 1006 and I'm
not on trt that is what happens when you
work with a proper comprehensive blood
panel company who genuinely knows what
they're doing with marck health it's
like having someone in your corner that
is a properly trained clinician who
knows exactly what's happening inside of
your body and can give you personalized
diet supplementation training and
pharmaceutical recommendations plus
organize it all it is a One-Stop shop
for your health you can get the exact
same medical panel and oversight that I
got by going to the link in the
description below or heading to Mari
health.com slod wisdom and using the
code modern wisdom a checkout for 10%
off that's m a k
health.com wisdom and modern wisdom a
checkout one person that I think's been
really interesting from this side you're
good friends with Tom seura yeah or
we're related we're cousins you're
kidding me no no no we're cousins I can
see it now uh his commitment to Fitness
has been pretty fascinating for me to
see and he's kind of treating his body
like an athlete to facilitate his chosen
pursuit of Comedy I think even Bert is
trying to sort his sort of health and
fitness out one step at a time too
Bert's the control
experiment like there's if if the
experiment is about willpower tenacity
and dis
Tom is the is the is the is the active
condition and Bert is the control but I
I'm seeing more and more people now
especially performers that aren't using
that aren't within the realm of physical
fitness really starting to understand if
I want to perform outside of this I need
to think like an athlete I need to be
looking at my hydration I mean Tom how
his trainer travel with him on the road
for months yeah yeah Tom's really
serious about his craft as is Bert they
just have different different approaches
and when it comes to Fitness I by the
way I noce Bert is training he's working
out I've been trying to get Bert to quit
drinking alcohol for a while um not
because I'm the um Arbiter of of of who
should do what I ne I never tell people
what to do by the way provide
information people can do what they want
I'm a Live and Let Live I want to be
very clear about that um but it's out of
uh care and affection for for Bert that
um you know excessive alcohol
consumption over long periods of time
bad I mean we can keep that one pretty
brief so but bird is working out but Tom
I know um because we talk and I spent
some time with him that uh he trains he
trains hard and he sees it as integral
with his with his writing with his
ability to show up for his family and
business Etc I mean you I think we're
finally approaching a time in human
history where we accept at the level of
you know the scientific Community all
the way through to Wellness and just
generally that the brain and body are
are intimately linked at the level of
what you you know if you want to improve
your body um do something for your mind
if you want to improve your mind do
something for your body and and it's so
clear now what we all need to do I mean
we we can get into the details but at a
macro level it's clear that we should
all be getting that 150 to 200 minutes
of Zone 2 per week or walking a lot if
you live in a big city you're probably
getting that but then also getting your
heart rate up to you know max heart rate
once a week doing some Sprint type stuff
on in whatever format is safe for your
body some people it's swimming some
people it's rowing some people it's
running for me it's running but you know
not everyone enjoys running or can do it
and then everyone should be doing at
least six sets of resistance training
per muscle group per week minimum hard
sets to failure okay maybe maybe not
close to failure yeah probably and it's
especially the groups that have been um
let's just say averse to weight training
right typically women El older folks
although now more women weight trained
because they understand that in the
absence of a lot of injected or
prescription anabolic hormones they're
not going to get um enormous that's the
funniest thing for me that's why we died
I think right that that concept that you
know if one lifts weights that they're
going to be get become bulky do you
realize to all of the women who are out
there that are concerned about lifting
weights because they're going to get too
bulky do you know how hard I've worked
to try and desperately become bulky for
15 years like I've worked really really
difficult hoping that one day I'll
become bulky and there is I think it's
dissipating a lot now but there was for
a long time this fear that do a couple
of bicep curs and you're going to look
like the Incredible Hulk it's like right
me and my friends have really really
prayed for that to happen forever uh you
do not need to be concerned it's not
going to creep up on you and one day
you're going to wake up and be this sort
of vascular Beast right um a couple
things about that I mean from a
longevity standpoint we know that
maintaining healthy nerve to muscle
function neuromuscular Junctions is one
of the things that resistance exercise
does and it's highly correlated with
cognitive function into older age um and
for those people I guess going back to
our earlier conversation we'll probably
do this a few times in the course of of
of this episode but um the thing you
want to do the least that's actually the
thing that where you stand to build up
your amcc the most so for me that would
be language learning or learning of
musical instruments to two things that I
love music and um but I I just it's just
so hard for me so it it sits there on
the Shelf as a possible way to activate
the amcc but in terms of actual uh
resistance training resistance training
has an interesting property that I
haven't heard discussed before um that
pertains to men and women who do it um
which is unlike iov vascular
training during a resistance training
bout because of the blood flow to the
muscle that so-called pump you get a
little window into what the potential
progress would look like that pump
dissipates post-workout and then if if
you allow sufficient rest and nutrition
Etc you'll get a hypertrophy response
but it's so unlike other forms of
exercise like if I go to a yoga class
and I stretch or I'm doing some movement
I get to that limit where I'm quaking
and I fall over it's very different than
getting a picture of just how flexible I
will be the next time and then losing
that until I adapt with running your
lungs sometimes your throat burns as you
pointed out and that's showing you your
limit and of course then there's an
adaptation response that then allows you
to perform at that level without the
burning in the next time right if you
allow sufficient recovery but with
weight training it's kind of interesting
the whole pump thing was never something
that I really drew me to weight training
very much but it's interesting because
you get a glimpse into what the the
progress might look like and so for I
would say for anyone who's worried about
getting too big unless your pump is
bigger than you want to be you're not
going to get that right and so you
actually get a window into um how much
potential size increase you're going to
create but it's so different than other
forms of exercise in that way it's like
what other thing in life like if you
took a language class and you're like oh
I'm going to learn Japanese and you go
and during the class you actually become
fluent for a moment then it's taken away
and then you adapt and become fluent so
it's it's a very special form of
exercise that that offers some unique um
gifts to us as incent incentives for
going back but look as I say this I
realize some people hate resistance
training they love running some people
hate running um they love resistance
training some people I realize hate
exercise yeah but if you hate exercise
you should do it anyway amcc and you're
getting the amcc so going back to what
you think might be happening to someone
like Tom who is a like a cognitive
athlete right but largely the Physical
Realm comedians apart from I guess until
Joe which is part of the beginning of
like the comedian bro bro lifter
Revolution before him it wasn't exactly
like I wasn't looking to comedians as
being the Vanguard of health and fitness
like B I mean look at balushi right I
mean he was the he was the epitome of
lack of health and sadly died right what
talk to me about what would be happening
to the brain of somebody like Tom who
pivots from being maybe 40 pounds
overweight I don't know how big he got
at his at his biggest but lost a good
bit of weight and it wasn't just losing
weight it was then gaining muscle so Dr
Gabrielle Lon world of like muscle
centered medicine he's going to benefit
from that the insulin sensitivity
there'll be like some physiological
changes but talk to me for the people
who are cognitive athletes what's going
to happen in someone like Tom's mind
when he changes his body yeah so
improved blood flow to the brain I mean
the brain is most metabolically
demanding organ in the entire body it
consumes a ton of glucose if you eat
carbohydrates yes it can run on ketones
but blood flow through arteries veins
and capillaries to the neurons of the
brain is is it's insep able from
cognitive function so when you improve
blood flow to the brain you improve
cognitive function period when you
restrict blood flow to the brain even at
a at a micro level you impair cognitive
function uh in addition to that um we
know that several forms of age related
cognitive decline and dementia are
considered nowadays some people will
even call it type 3 diabetes although
that's a controversial term diabetes of
the brain this is why a number of people
who have Alzheimer's go on ketogenic
diets and get some degree of relief it's
not that it by the way it's not a cure
for Alzheimer's but some people do
better when they switch the major fuel
source for the brain but in the case of
Tom as an example but someone who gets
into exercising regularly both
resistance training and cardiovascular
training you're getting improved blood
flow you're getting far less
inflammation of the brain inflammation
is cognitive depleting uh reducing
inflammation cognitive enhancing we all
that's absolutely true across the board
right in animal studies and humans in
addition to that there are a lot of
bloodborne factors two of which which
I'll just highlight now just for sake of
time only too first of all when we do
cardio that it positively impact brain
health and memory in particular so when
we do loadbearing
cardiovascular exercise so running uh as
opposed to swimming um anything where
where the skeletal system is is under
some load there's a hormone that's
literally secreted from bone I know we
don't normally think of Bones as
endocrine organs called osteocalcin
osteocalcin is released from the bones
under these loadbearing conditions it
can cross the bloodb brain barrier and
we know that it plays an active role in
promoting not just new cell production
but because that's a more minor
component of neuroplasticity but um
enhancement of nerve health and function
in the hippocampus which is an area
that's instrumental for the formation of
new memories so there's something about
movement of the body that signals to the
brain ah we're you know we're moving you
you actually need to maintain or perhaps
even enhance your ability to remember
things and this probably is an
evolutionary conserved circuit that
exists we know it exists in mice as well
so that's one one example the other is
that my colleague at Stan Stanford Tony
Weiss Corey um is best known for these
um young blood experiments where they'll
take the blood or plasma from a young
rodent and put it into an aged or
demented rodent and see improvements in
cognitive function and outside the
United States there are some clinics by
the way I'm not recommending people do
this that have shown improvements in
cognitive function or even offsetting of
Alzheimer's and age related cognitive
decline this has led to the idea of like
vampires and baby blood and this whole
Drome yeah Dr it's which is all crazy in
conspiracy I'm go on record saying that
but there's a recent paper that also
from Tony's lab showing that if in
animals that exercise regularly if you
take their blood or plasma and you
supply that blood or plasma to aged or
cognitively deficient animals they their
cognition or their cognitive abilities
improve so there's something about blood
of the exercised body that enriches the
brain it could be many different growth
factors it could be bdnf brain derve
neutrophic Factor it could be things
like igf-1 insulin light growth factor
it's probably G to be a a cocktail of
different things um as well as
osteocalcin and so what we want to think
about is that when we exercise and
that's a broad statement exercise or
word rather cardiovascular resistance
training it creates a a cocktail that
then crosses into the blood brain
barrier that then creates a mill you of
General growth health or at least
maintenance of of cognitive tissue
that's there so Tom's incredibly sharp
and of course comedy requires not just
memory but also writing of new jokes
right he's he's got to do Netflix
specials for a long time and I actually
went and saw him in Aspen a small venue
I flew out there to see him because I
wanted to see him in a small venue
because in small venues is where Comics
often work out their new material and I
mean just you know to me it was just
astonishing like to see the number of
different threads and one thing that
makes Tom's comedy so wonderful and
other people like Richard prior did this
exceptionally well too is that he can
switch personas very fast so he's doing
his voice then he switches to his son's
voice and switches back and the speed
and precision with which he does that
very agile makes it seem we forget that
they're very agile and then we we've he
creates a a panel of characters and then
wipes that board away right he's the
only guy up there wipes that board away
and then creates a panel of new
characters and so I mean that requires a
lot of Dex like cognitive dexterity so
exercise is absolutely one of the best
ways to improve brain function over time
and in addition to that you know there's
been so much interest in you know should
we do crossword puzzles should we you
know why is it that some people maintain
cognitive function I think what's very
clear to me based on all that literature
is that it's not one specific thing
crossword puzzles or social engagement
or exercise it's all of those things but
let's not forget the superagers the
people who are constantly trying things
that are difficult that are pressuring
themselves a bit to do things that are
difficult those people are offsetting as
far as we know all of the major
shrinkage of these brain structures that
normally would shrink as people age so
we have a lot of control but it does
require effort and I'll tell you there's
never going to be a pillar injection it
whether or not it's OIC or something
like it but for the brain there's just
no there's no way there's no way that
you're ever going to recapitulate
learning and effort um and yes it
requires time but it's it's so clear I
mean I don't know how many more papers
in preclinical models and in humans one
needs to see before they finally just
you know bite the bullet and go lift
weights lift weights and run or and do
cardiovascular training it can't be one
or the other you know the the The
Stereotype of like the the big let's
just say big guy who's dumb you know I I
don't think it's entirely um I mean you
meet some big big folks that are smart
right but there is
something in the kind of broad
correlations of people who you know R
people who tend to only do
cardiovascular training you know maybe
it's it's a selection bias like they're
the people who are already Avid readers
or more kind of intellectual leanings
maybe get more involved in tennis
swimming running type Sports rowing
because of the schools they went to or
whatever but people who just lift
weights it does seem as if over time I
don't know maybe dererk would tell us
their neck is getting too big they have
sleep apnea it it they they don't seem
as sharp and they're often mouth
breathers look at the really big guys in
the gymm they're often not strong not
just between sets not just after hard
sets they're I think they're also
they're asfixia themselves in sleep we
know this yeah um and then you look at
Runners and the people that have the
kind of like the really spelt and and
and they um and sure they might maintain
cognitive function but their bodies are
very vulnerable to injury and they
always seem to be complaining about what
hurts you know there like my friends who
do a lot of extended training unless
it's David hin who doesn't seem to have
the circuit for complaining um at least
certainly not online um yeah they always
seem to be complaining about about
injuries so I think a combination of
resistance training and cardiovascular
training is let's just face it like you
can't do one and not the other if you
want to be healthy all around healthy of
heart healthy of body healthy of Mind
cognition um improved or or at least
maintained as we age you got to do both
we'll get back to talking to Andrew in
one minute but first I need to tell you
about element element contains a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium that will
help to regulate your appetite curb
cravings and optimize your brain health
you do not need coffee first thing in
the morning you're a Denine system that
caffeine act on isn't even active for
the first 90 minutes of the day but your
adrenal system is and salt act on your
adrenal system best of all it just
tastes phenomenal this orange flavor is
honestly like a Godly nectar that I've
been taking every single morning for
over 3 years even when I'm on the road
out here in La it is the first thing
that I reach for every single morning
best of all they having no BS no
questions ask refund policy where you
can buy it 100% risk-free And if you do
not like it for any reason you can get
your money back and you don't even need
to return the box that's how confident
they are that you love it head to the
link in the description below or go to
drink LM nt.com slod wisdom to get a
free sample pack of all eight flavors
with your first box that's drink LM
nt.com
slod wisdom coming back to the
discussion about alcohol which is one
that you tried to interject with Berton
I think your episode that you released
last year yeah back end of last summer I
think that really opened a lot of
people's eyes to some of the risks of
alcohol I've been kind of flying the
flag of it as a tool for productivity
for quite a while to avoid alcohol yeah
that I think when you entirely or or do
do you drink at all uh I've brought it
back into my life now but I did six
months sober three times and then a
thousand days without alcohol too um but
yeah I'm seeing right now a huge push
back against
unseen
unintentional drinking and I think that
yeah your episode last year opened a lot
of people's eyes to it thanks I mean
again I I don't tell people what to do I
give them the facts so they can make the
best decisions for them I mean it's very
clear that unless you're an
alcoholic and provided you're an adult
that you know two drinks per week
maximum um is about the upper threshold
Beyond which you're going to start
getting some health called that's called
a warm-up to a warm-up in England yeah
so so I you know I've never been a big
drinker I don't drink um I I'm lucky
that it's not something that's that's a
strong draw for me you know I have
friends that are recovered alcoholics um
and you know their lives are so much
better as a function of being sober but
for non-alcoholics I mean I think
everyone should just know the uh the
health risks especially women where the
risks for breast cancer and other types
of cancers are are elevated so very much
and what was interesting uh to me about
the response to that episode is that I
think many people took it my the
impression I got was that many people
took it as permission to finally stop
drinking or drink less because they
didn't enjoy drinking and as you so you
know beautifully put out on social media
you know drinking is one of the few
activities that if you don't partake
people assume or accuse you of having a
problem and it's just wild I mean like
why would that be and I think that I
think it also make once actually I was
out to dinner with a colleague years ago
and I declined drink that even I was
just talking to the the visiting speaker
and um she said God that's so boring and
I well first of all I don't have a
problem saying what's on my mind without
alcohol right I don't have I don't have
a excessive gabic inhibition um so I'll
say what I want to say um you know as uh
as best I can but you know I think
drinkers don't like people who don't
drink because it takes the fun out of it
for them because there is this idea
that's you know prolific on college
campuses like if everyone's drunk that
somehow like the entire like Vibe of the
party is going to take on a new new
flavor and frankly I remember I went to
a college UC Santa Barbara where at the
time people drank a ton a ton discovered
alcoholics you right um and I used to go
to parties sometimes I look around I'm
thinking like everyone here is just
blasted like if anything happen were you
drinking did you drinking yeah I drank
in college but not that often I I had a
habit and I don't recommend this I had a
habit of going out about once a month
and I would tie one on you know
absolutely infrequent but binge yeah I
never you know I my tolerance to alcohol
was always such that I would get drunk
quickly and then sober up really fast so
I was drinking late into the night um
but then I'd sober up really fast now of
course we know the sleep you get after
even one drink is vastly diminished
every single person that's got a aura or
a whoop strap or something is feeling
you right now um and I think that
alcohol to me um never felt good I never
liked it and it was a recipe for you
know there was a lot of fights there was
a lot of you know there were a lot of
bad stuff happens when people are
drinking too much drunk driving to say
nothing of poor decision making I mean I
to me it just feels like there's so
there are so many better ways to have a
good time that that that alcohol isn't
necessary but I do understand that it's
a big part of many cultures and I do
understand that for many people it's so
part- and parcel with um relaxing and
with festivity
and with feeling comfortable and with
drawing a boundary between the normal
day and the rest of the day that's
interesting there's a ritualistic aspect
to it yeah there's a sort of it divides
the day in an interesting way so I'm not
judgmental of it I but um for me I mean
I'll go to a party where people are
drinking and just hang out I'm perfectly
good dude I've stood on the door of a
thousand club nights in my career right
as a club promoter and I can promise you
for the people that are thinking I like
the sound of this justification this
excuse that I don't need to drink
anymore Dr hubman has said that you know
maybe it's not for you maybe it's not as
enjoyable nothing good happens in
nightclubs after 1 in the morning I am
patient zero I have the I Am the Doctor
of late night parties okay like that's
one of my expertise nothing good happens
in the nightclub it's this sort of
messy
sloppy fights and kissing people you
shouldn't and and and stumbling all over
the place and stuff if you go out and
you don't drink and you go home at 1:00
in the morning I think you probably get
to capture about
80% of the enjoyment of the event that
you would have done had you have drank
pre-drinks gone out done the whole thing
and I got a bit of push I got quite a
bit of push back from a sobriety
Community a few years ago I did this
thousand days sober as a club promoter
which was I guess like a kind of a big
deal in some regards for like pushing
the sobriety Community forward but I was
never doing it because I had a problem I
was doing it because it gave me more
consistency and more time and more money
to spend on things that I cared about so
it was a a productivity tool like like
the pomodora technique right or going to
bed on time or something and um they had
a little bit of a problem they had a big
problem with the fact that I said there
is something to the enjoyment of
drinking on a night out I think anybody
that says alcohol has no role in
improving the quality of a night out
ever just hasn't been on enough good
nights out right there there are ways
that it can can improve kind of loosens
people up it can reduce their
inhibitions if you want to go and dance
you know you're dancing at a rave or or
at a festival which I think there's one
going on quite close to here um if
you're there it's really great
but if alcohol wasn't so widely
distributed I think people would ask a
lot more questions it's like you can't
see the wood for the trees right you you
don't question it it's such a it's baked
into the the fabric of of just human
life every single time that I take a
like a macro dose but low of psilocybin
one where I can still function what is
what is um 75 75 to 1 gr so so that's
about it's a little less than half of
the macro therapeutic dose for for
intractable depression which is
something like 2.2 grams or so so you
can still hold a conversation depending
on what strain you've got but every
single time that I do it without fail a
thought comes into my mind which is why
does anyone drink alcohol why does
anybody do it because I'll go to bed my
HRV my recovery is fine the next day
maybe I'm a little bit tired like I've
had a lot of like activation I've been
super
energetic very little hangover on the
evening I don't do stupid things it
makes me want to say nice things to all
of my friends my thoughts are sharper
than they were before sometimes they're
silly but they're sharper and then you
compare it with alcohol and it's this
kind of sloppy muddy very unile it's
it's just I I I totally get what you
mean when you've taken a little bit of
time away from it and you look at it in
the harsh light of day the effect that
alcohol gives you just aren't that
enjoyable and it's been folded into
people's lives through tradition and
through just anchoring bias and
continuation yeah and marketing you know
the idea that like someone can quote
unquote hold their liquor is such like a
it's been um made synonymous with you
know masculine ideals it's like I mean
it's it's kind of crazy because we know
it also it crushes testosterone levels
what's interesting is that um you know I
I forget who said this but you know
there's a very different picture of a
young drunk versus an old drunk you know
someone who's been just drinking for too
many years it's not a pretty picture s
they become infantile they become really
infantile and um you know again I'm I'm
not the anti-alcohol Crusader we did I
did that episode not expecting much of a
response actually um that shows just how
out of uh out of touch sometimes I can
be I think just to reiterate it man I
think it gave people the excuse what you
did is you gave people the justification
you legitimized them it's like the best
bucks tell you something that you
already know it was like they everyone
always lots of people always had an idea
I probably shouldn't be drinking maybe I
don't enjoy it that much maybe these
aren't my friends they're just my
drinking Partners maybe I don't like the
way that I feel the next day maybe my
life could be better if I sto
drinking there's the justification well
I'm happy to hear that for those folks
you know now the information is out
there I've um I was accused several
times uh on Twitter t/x of um taking all
the fun out of parties in the at least
in the Bay Area but I'll tell you I grew
up in the Bay Area the good parties
ended a long time ago but they still
exist you know I mean I think they you
know and when I say other ways to have
fun I don't mean like oh everyone should
sit around do math or read Neuroscience
although for me that's fun um you know I
think I
think in a broader sense I think there's
a shift nowadays that people really
think about you know how to engage
socially in ways that are interesting I
mean perhaps it's a again a sample bias
because of the topics that I cover and
who talks to me but like in the Bay Area
there are these Russian Bas in New York
there's spy 88 by the way they don't pay
me and say this but I like to go this uh
Russian B down in Wall Street you go
there and you know got hot saunas and
cold plunge and people are you know
young people are there enjoying
themselves and they actually serve
alcohol so they'll have sometimes
they'll do like little gimlets of of
vodka or something there and so you know
people sometimes that's part of the
tradition the most Russian thing that I
can think of shot of vodka whilst hot
right so that and you know they've got
theories as to how that can help and
listen I think some of those Traditions
can really be wonderful but you know
people are starting to combine
socializing with health promoting
protocols and you know going out and
eating good food together like eating
really wonderful food um with the social
component the you know I I'll go into
the grave talking about getting morning
sunlight something that maybe we should
talk a little bit more about and as
people like roll their eyes I'll just
say there's this incredible study now
just out in nature um mental health
published about 80 that has 8 5,000
85,000 subjects showing that the ratio
of getting a lot of sunlight during the
day to getting minimal artificial light
exposure at night it really sets the
tone of your overall system and is and
is associated with brain and body that
is and is associated with better mental
health outcomes across the board and the
inverse right if you're getting too much
artificial light at night or not enough
sunlight or both is associated with
everything bad Elevate depression
anxiety Etc now I do believe people
should get out and have a good time
don't avoid the bright lights of a city
or a club have a great time like dancing
socializing those are great reasons to
stay up too late and get minimal sleep
or sleep in the next day great reasons
so every once in a while sure 10 20% of
your life you're going to do that and
probably some percentage of time is also
going to be raising kids so you're up
because you have to to keep keep them
alive which is important to our species
so thank you but I think people you know
forget that yes you can go outside and
get morning sunlight and which I highly
recommend people do that as as most
people know but I mean so many benefits
on mood and mental health and Improv
sleep that you just and it's completely
zero cost you know but I often get
accused of okay well but what if you
have kids like how do you do this well
you take the kids with you because guess
what they need it too you you take them
outside you eat breakfast outside or at
least facing a window indoors it's not
going to be as good as having the window
open or being outdoors but even if the
sun's on the other side of your
apartment building I mean these things
have an outsize positive effect on
health and I'll wager both upper limbs
anyway uh that many many many of the the
mental health issues that we see
nowadays in young people and in adults
is the consequence of disrupted
circadian rhythms because of a lot of
time in a two-dimensional screen space
which I'm not condemning I spend time on
and put out most of my content on social
media and YouTube Apple Spotify right um
and in addition to that to the lights
are too bright at night and they're not
getting enough sunlight during the day
and an important thing to understand
about our circadian Health you know
circadian system in health is is that
throughout in the morning and throughout
the day your eyes are less sensitive to
light and you need more of it in order
to get what you need okay broadly
speaking and at night your eyes are far
more sensitive to artificial lighting
and you need far less of it in order to
disrupt your circadian system in bad
ways disrupt your mental health now does
that mean you have to walk around with
sunglasses at night and you know Dim All
the Lights in your house well no but you
could afford to dim them a little bit um
you could afford to switch to the red
light function on your phone there's
actually a triple click red light
function on every phone that um maybe
I'll pass the the the throughput of what
to do to your phone it's which allows
you to accessibility functions on on
iPhone think mine goes to mine goes to
grayscale when I do that yeah you can
yeah so you can have it switch to
grayscale or to purely red uh you know
eliminate the blues a trick that my
friend Rick Ruben taught me I was like
oh this is great you know you don't you
know you don't necessarily have to
purchase blue blocker glasses or
anything like that we'll get back to
talking to Andrew in one minute but
first I need to tell you about mudwater
mudwater is a coffee alternative that
tastes like chai and cacao had a baby
it's got four functional mushrooms and
with only a fraction the caffeine as a
cup of coffee you will get all of the
natural energy without the Jitters or
crash each ingredient was added for a
purpose cacao and chai for a hint of
coffee and hot chocolate likee flavor
Lion's man for Focus ceps to promote
Natural Energy and both Chara and re
sheet to support a healthy immune system
plus it's Whole 30 approved 100% USDA
organic certified non-GMO gluten-free
vegan and kosher so if you're looking
for a delicious alternative to your
morning coffee this is a great place to
start right now you can get $20 off your
first order plus a whole box of good
stuff including Creer and a free fror by
going to the link in the description
below or heading to mudw tr.com
Modern wisdom that's mud wt.com
slod wisdom so there are a bunch of
little things that we can do that make a
vast Improvement in the way that our
biology and psychology function and it
it's amazing when you start to think
about how most people exist now it's too
dim not enough light for them during the
day especially not enough sunlight and
then it's too bright for them at night
and they're also living mostly in a
two-dimensional world of screens what's
what's the problem with the
two-dimensional thing well the you know
the we have an epidemic of myopia of
nearsightedness and it's been shown in a
bunch of different clinical trials now
the first couple of them that were
attacked like most studies something
comes out then it gets attacked then
there's a retaliation study Etc um that
kids that spend two hours or more outof
doors per day have a far lower incidence
of myopia nearsightedness and even if
they're on iPads and and books and
computers there's something about far
viewing about viewing things further
than three or four feet away from us on
a frequent for a significant portion of
our day doesn't mean you have to be
staring off into the Horizon but as
opposed to near viewing where you're
looking at something within about four
feet of oneself this distance that we're
sitting across from one another is about
probably about four and a half five feet
um it's not quite far viewing but you
think about watch people's behavior look
at how they go through the day they're
spending most of their time looking at
things about a foot to a foot and a half
away and as a consequence the eyeball
gets longer this is a wellestablished
fact in animal models and humans and
then the visual image isn't focused onto
the retina the light sensing portion at
the back of the eye the image Falls in
front of the Rea so-called
nearsightedness right it's falling too
near to the lens okay there are other
some people claim that near sidess has
to do with the actual perceptual changes
but in any event so fortunately that the
eyeball actually can change in length so
viewing things further away can actually
especially early in life allow the
eyeball to adjust its shape amazing just
like the sinuses these there's
plasticity of a lot of different organs
and so the point is that we need to get
out and view things at a distance if
you're walking down the street looking
at your phone you're you're you're
degrading the functioning of your visual
system well I told you I I think I
texted you before I did it I got laser
eye surgery a month ago oh yeah so you
got the lasic yes great and that's so
the lasic just to you know educate
people is to actually change the shape
of the eyeball somewhat um in order to
make it more perfect optically um in a
way that for many people allows them to
not have to wear corrective lenses of
any kind yeah I can see everything I can
see your ancestral trauma and and and
full works now at 100 yards amazing your
vision is super sharp now correct oh
it's 2015 what was the was the surgery
painful it's very interesting so um I
actually videoed it I haven't put it up
because it's kind of it's probably
pretty uncomfortable for people to watch
um never stopped you before that's true
that's true so um they numb both of your
eyes using numbing drops okay and then
they come over the top with a kind of a
large box on an arm they rest the valve
of the front of this box on the eyeball
itself and then suck the eyeball onto
the actual valve so that it can't move
they then use one laser to create a flap
in the cornea which is at the uh precise
distance based on all of the tests they
did in the days prior to that they then
take it off
mhm you'll you're still lying back you
have to keep looking at a green light
that's above you the uh surgeon will
lift the flap the front flap of the
cornea up yeah using kind of a soft pair
of tweezers yeah the laser will then
come in behind now the opened part of
the cornea do the corrective surgery the
flap will then get replaced uh and and
it needs to to be very very very precise
so that any slight nudge I actually had
to go and get the uh I had to get my
flap rifted uh a couple of days later on
my left eye because a tiny tiny tiny
little bit of oil from the top of my
eyelid had been caught underneath the
flap and it was causing a flaring of
bright lights and um so I had to go back
and actually get the flap rifted get
this the flap that they make can still
be rifted up to 3 years later amazing
it's fascinating um and yeah how done on
both eyes couple of one day of recovery
it feels very gritty for the people that
are concerned about whether or not it's
it's going to like hurt them and my
recovery period was one day and I was
able to I recorded a Podcast 48 hours in
Bright Lights 48 Hours afterward was it
an expensive procedure four grand GBP so
five grand uh USD not a trivial sum not
a trivial sum but also given that it's
literally how you navigate the world
sure uh and I was squinting a lot I was
squinting at screens to have read the
text I was using really large text the
only reason I found out about this is
because I went in for a checkup and they
got me to do my eye test and the lady
turned and said yeah you um you legally
can't drive without glasses and I was
like what are you talking about my
vision's my vision's great like my
vision's always been like this but she
got me to do the thing and I
thought yeah it shouldn't be I should be
able to read those huge letters that are
only 20 ft away from me shouldn't I and
uh sure enough after this corrective
surgery 2015 vision everything's razor
sharp um the only considerations that I
would say are nighttime viewing of
Bright Lights specifically uh street
lights cars coming toward you you get a
little bit of flaring around them um and
that's because it's now passing through
not just one piece of material but there
is a second cut um that supposedly
dissipates a little bit over time but uh
I am flying the flag for uh Laser Eye
Treatment man it's it's been a complete
Game Changer my pickle ball games
improved which is obviously what was
most important um everything's it's
really really good and I'm I'm very very
impressed and thank you to my surgeon
for doing it yeah so that this little
flap did they tell you how big the flap
is I can just show you the video I can
show you the video once we finish up uh
interesting um thanks for sharing that
yeah I think it's an interesting
procedure and um we did an episode with
our chair of Opthalmology Jeff Goldberg
and um he was a proponent of it for
people that are you know I Tex I texted
you to make sure that like the
opthalmologist guy with all of the dudes
that know it like am I all right to do
this Jeff's amazing actually we we
trained in the same lab he was a gradu
student I was a postto then he ended up
in Miami and then we converged in San
Diego Then he moved to Stanford I moved
to Stanford so I we sort of he'll argue
I was tracking him I'll argue he was
tracking me but um he's my chairman so
I'll just say I was tracking him um but
very very smart guy and and I think yeah
getting keeping your eyes healthy is key
this actually comes back to light um so
there's some really beautiful data of
Glenn Jeff's Laboratory University
College London I've known Glenn for more
than 20 years he's a spectacular Vision
scientist um showing that exposure to
artificial red light you know there's a
lot of the you know like the ju and
these other red lights that are out
there cozy and these other red light
systems which by the way I don't have
any Financial relationship to um you
know the idea that red light could
somehow enhance different functions of
our tissues or preserve different
functions of our tissues people think
it's really biohack like oh this is you
know blender red lights but you know
there was a Nobel Prize given for the
use of long wavelength light for the
treatment of Lupus like almost 100 years
ago so the idea of phototherapy Is Not A
New Concept but people love to to kind
of push it into the realm of of um
biohacking broides but it's not um red
light therapy has been shown to have
some positive outcomes for treatment of
acne for scar healing and wound healing
uh red light is long wavelength light
which can penetrate further through
tissues than short wavelength light so
that's sort of the argument there is
that when you look at red light or R red
light is placed on or shown on the skin
some of it is actually getting into the
deeper layers of the dermis how deep
it's questionable some people argue that
they can even get into the the blood
supply if you know it's like on the
wrist or something in any event Glenn's
lab has shown two really important
findings and the first one they've shown
twice in separate studies and this is
all in
humans the first result is that if
people look at red light for two or
three minutes once or twice a week in
particular early in the day it can
offset some age related vision loss how
well the photo receptors of the back of
the eye are some of the most
metabolically uh de consum metabolically
active and um let's just say energy
consuming cells of the entire nervous
system which is saying a lot because the
nervous system is the most metabolically
cons consuming or metabolically excuse
me active organ and so as a consequence
these really active cells create a lot
of so-called reactive oxygen species and
that imp impacts the negatively impacts
the functions of mitochondria so viewing
red light seems to restore some of the
mitochondrial function by limiting
reactive oxygen species in the photo
receptors and offsetting and they've
shown this some not all but some age
related vision loss presumably you're
not talking about looking at one of
these red light panels because these
things are like a a [__] like flat
it's hu it's so bright am I actually am
referring to that but you want to do it
at a distance that's comfortable so
several feet right those panels for the
people that don't know these things
bright uh inide they even provide you
with like yeah like the stuff for the
for the sunbed goes with them yeah so
you don't want to do this for more than
a couple of minutes and you do want to
Blink and you do and probably through ey
eyelids closed if your eyelids are thin
enough and it's bright enough it can
probably get in nonetheless but let let
me be very very clear um well I'll tell
you the other result and then I'll tell
you why you don't need necessarily need
a red light um the other result which is
more recent and is still under review so
I want to be very clear but the the data
look interesting um um to say the least
is that there's this old Theory like old
theory that the French have really
expounded that you know eating food
Outdoors is metabolized differently than
eating food indoors which sounds crazy
right I mean at some level and yet this
study shows that if people do this red
light
viewing while eating or in the minutes
just after eating for just a few minutes
that the postmeal blood glucose level
sever is significantly dampened which is
a good thing right you don't want big
elevations in blood glucose or excessive
elevations in blood glucose now that all
sounds a little bit at the edge of what
we consider you know valid uh or
reasonable and yet if you think about
sunlight sunlight is full spectrum light
so this isn't saying you need to run out
and buy a red light this is if you get
outside and get your morning sunlight
yes it's going to set your circadian
rhythm for elevated mood focus and
alertness during the day improve sleep
at night but in addition that you're
getting red light to your eyes early in
the day
you you absolutely you're getting red
light to your eyes now on very densely
overcast days say in the UK or elsewhere
it's not you're going to really filter
out the the clouds are going to filter
out the red light The Joy the will to
live and um and as a consequence some
people choose to supplement their light
with these red light devices um but this
idea that the French and others have
have argued and I'm sure as I say the
French said it then you know the French
will nod and everyone else will say no
it's like it was us first or us also
multiple uh people throughout history
groups throughout history but it does
seem that there's something different
about the way that food is
metabolized if under different lighting
conditions which sounds crazy and I I
can already hear Lane Norton stomping in
with his you know B basically yeah Lane
Lane's brain sort of has like Pub met
ideas I I I think it's great by the way
lane we love you um and I love his his
um his uh sort of um adherence to Pub
IDs but you know these are published
studies I'll send along you can tell me
what you think Lane but um the point
being that there still needs to be more
work on this right but it's always nice
when some nicely controlled studies done
by wellestablished Laboratories that
people in a field trust like Glenn's lab
um start seeing things once or twice
over in multiple studies um that really
work well with what we know from kind of
naturalistic conditions for instance
they Hunters people that are adventurers
that are whose job depends on them being
able to see into the distance Cameron
Haynes yeah cam Haynes these people
maintain Vision well into their older
age just nerds like me who spend too
much time in front of a book or a screen
who spend most of their time and have
for many years looking at things down I
mean for years I looked at things down a
microscope that was where most of my
life was down looking down the
microscope but also reading things at
close distance well you know it makes
sense that the eyeball would lengthen
you end up with near sidess I do wear
corrective lenses um at night especially
if I'm Drive driving at night I've
really worked hard to try to not succumb
to the need for corrective lenses
because I'm trying to keep my vision
health good and when I you become
Reliant I don't want to become reliant
on it but but you know at night I have
to wear corrective lenses yeah talking
about the red light stuff have you heard
of huberman husbands do you know what
this is yeah um unfortunately well I I
should say that the most unfortunate
thing about the huberman husbands post
is that it was about is that it was
taken by certain media Outlets to
amplify the idea that the audience of my
podcast is just male when in fact it's
50% male female at least in the
listenership YouTube Excuse male but we
knew that anyway um but the listenership
is 50% male 50% female and the huberman
husbands thing um was really about how a
woman was saying that she thinks she's
the huberman husband because she does
all these different things that but they
got taken from that for the people that
don't know that the meta meme around
huberman husbands which you can search
on Tik Tok right now is that the hot new
thing that all of the wives want out
there is a husband who's into red light
therapy and he does cold plunges and he
does Sauna treatments and stuff so I I
wondered see guys I'm trying to help you
out look dude I I wondered how you feel
of a bunch of guys potentially
cosplaying as Andrew huberman in the
bedroom like the price of long sleeve
black shirts has gone through the roof
you now have people fully Ling as you
maybe they're they're telling them
telling their wife that didn't get
enough sunlight in their eyes as dirty
talk in the bedroom I'm not sure I
wondered how it feels to have this Army
of Andrew huberman from wish now
existing on on the internet so so we
covered the amcc it means interior mid
singulate cortex but I confess even
though I know that I don't know what
cosplay is and I don't know what laring
is cosplay is dressing up it's it
happens at um a lot of conventions
someone will go as Anakin Skywalker or
Pikachu or whatever and Ling his life
for sexual titilation
sometimes but not always uh this is sort
of like a this is the this is like the
action hero um variation on furries kind
of yeah but it's not fur is more Lex's
domain precisely yeah we know we know
that well uh and then we know that but
we don't know it well fortunately
liveaction role playing Ling so that
again is this kind of I'm saying there
are potentially there is potentially a
market out there if a guy is struggling
in the dating world
to take the aesthetic get fully hu and
pilled and then there is a a huge
potential demand amongst the wives out
there okay so um this is news to me um
one thing that's come up recently in
discussions with some traditional media
Outlets but but also just generally
right is you know to what extent is all
this focus on health um you know does
that change something about masculine
feminine Dynamics like like the the
traditional um stereotype of men was
that they're tough enough to not need to
engage in any self-care right they don't
need sleep they can drink a lot of
liquor they'll eat when there's food
they'll eat whatever they don't like
going to the doctor right this this like
runs very countercurrent to the kinds of
things I talk about my podcast like hey
get up in the morning get some sunlight
right uh lift weights run um and I
should point out that n none of what
I've talked about with exercise ever of
course there's an aesthetic component
right limiting body fat to some extent
right not having excessive body fat um
you know resistance training as we know
is an incredible way to adjust this
one's Aesthetics if they feel like their
proportions aren't where they want or
you know by the way guys train your neck
uh clearly Chris does um I mean nothing
looks more ridiculous than like wide
shoulder big body and a little and a
head with a Little Neck neck I mean it's
well it's just it's crazy because it's
proportionally you see it and you're
like this is it's the it's the male
equivalent of the BBL if you have like a
I'm teaching you I'm so happy that I get
to teach you this is s like class for me
I've got make sure that you've got your
notes so this is the Brazilian buttlift
it's kind of like the bum equivalent of
a boob job and they have an implants for
the glutes I think that they actually
take fat from elsewhere in the body uh
and then put it into the it's the uh
risk the uh surgery risk of this is
really quite high they just do like hip
thrusters or something isn't there that
there's um that takes too long there's
the Brett contras glute guy yeah yeah
yeah he's pop because he he puts glutes
on people but they actually put them on
themselves CU they're the ones doing the
work I think the doctor technically puts
it on them but yeah and it kind of looks
because there's no Associated leg
development with the glute development
it's kind of like if you put two
basketballs on upturned baseball bats so
you have like a the leg and then you
have like ridiculous it's I've seen some
I went to Miami for the first time a few
months ago and I saw one that kind of
terrified me it looked like a bag of
cats from behind in a set of leggings uh
you like you could kind of see sort of
Paws coming out like this moves poorly
poorly finished I would say impant moves
I just it wasn't wasn't good anyway my
point being uh neck for guys need to
have it proportional to the shoulders
yeah it I mean yeah so I'm sort of
taking Digs at people that don't train
their neck it's also life insurance
right um I had an accident a few years
ago where I fell off a second story roof
and I walked away from it because I've
long done neck training because I
injured my neck when I was younger and
um even if you don't do Sports I don't
do fight sports but um wouldn't be uh
aligned with my my role needing my brain
um and I got nothing against people that
do fight sports but that's a choice that
I've I've actively made not to do them
anymore um but neck trainings is really
important for what's the at20 of neck
training what what's are the biggest
movers for improving your neck oh well
first of all I'll tell you in a moment
um but I think that you know remember
that your neck is your upper spine so
people are big on training their abs you
know for for spine stability and lower
back hopefully as well for spine
stability the midthoracic regions as
well but you know it's your upper spine
and and you want it strong and you um
you'll get much stronger in other things
as well everything's better people's
posture is far better when they train
their neck it actually changes the tone
of people's voice and I had a guest on
my podcast Dr Eddie Chang who's our
chair of neurosurgery at UCSF I've known
him since we were kids um he's
phenomenally smart and creative guy and
I've asked him about this offline you
know why is it that neck training does
that well you know the voice change that
occurs in boys when they um when they
develop and go through puberty is a
thickening of the vocal cords that's
Androgen dependent I have this weird
mutation I've talked about this a little
bit but maybe not um that on a program
as broad as this that actually have the
same voice I always had from when I was
a little kid my voice never actually
changed I have a s I have an androgen
receptor uh alteration okay um so
fortunately for me like doesn't cause
any other issues but this was my voice
when I was 5 years old how terrifying
yeah they called me froggy yeah it was
kind of a joke like the kid on The
Little Rascals that was froggy in any
case but for most people they hit
puberty and then their voice changes
because of the thickening of the vocal
cords but obviously I had some early
Androgen exposure um that was clear
because I also had hair on my Adams
Apple when I was like four years old so
there was some early Androgen exposure
I'm not going to [__] with that foury
old no well I was I was a kind kid until
I was a teenager and then I eventually
angry teenag I went through it but you
know I was I was kind nonetheless but in
any event um when you train your neck
actually um it it does improve posture
and it actually changes the tamber of
your voice somewhat um but for people
who speak a lot for a living podcasters
singers actors Etc lawyers and lawyers
seem to talk a lot um you don't want to
do a lot of really heavy neck training
because it actually changes the way that
your jaw moves and the way that you
speak and you know you and I especially
like my solo podcast that sometimes take
me 11 hours to record and um so you want
to maintain healthy air flow through
through this region right um but the
best way to develop a strong neck safely
is to unfortunately stay away from
Bridges which you know wrestling coaches
love to give you can the discs can can
be injur you can you can cause
dysfunction of the discs and then the
pain comes on in a moment and then
you're you're you're hosed um best thing
to do is take a plate and start really
light lie on a bench stabilize yourself
by putting one arm down okay so you want
to close the chain so to speak if you
can get a a foot down as well and then
put that plate you know probably start
with a five or a 10 PB plate wrapped in
a towel so you don't end up with an
imprint of the five or 10 on the side of
your head or face and then you're you're
just going to go from neutral position
which is your head you know essentially
straight up and down but you're lying on
your side to just you know uh about
maybe 30 or 45 degrees you don't like
really cinch into it and you want to
keep this is important keep your tongue
on the roof of your mouth your jaw shut
so that your jaw are moving around
because some people do neck work and
then they'll get clicking of the jaw
they get pain in the ear there's I've
spent a lot of time with skulls and I
can tell you human skulls and other
skulls by virtue of my work in
neuroscience and dissecting stuff and I
kind of obsession with crano facial
stuff as well and you know there's a lot
of musculature and ligaments of the the
skull that have to be contended with so
tongue on the roof of your mouth and
you're just going to you know nasal
breathe and you're not going to failure
you're not training really heavy higher
reps in the you know 10 to 25 repetition
range three sets yeah three sets and
then the other side and then you know
rather than doing a lot of forward
neetwork which people are already doing
because they're doing a lot of phone
reading and shaping themselves like a c
you want to lie on your stomach and put
a plate on the back of your head and get
into that you know the the neck
extension straight back but not pinching
or wrenching your head back movements
like where you're creating some torsion
up into the sides like this is a little
more dangerous I don't recommend um the
person who has great tutorials on this
and many other things as well as Jeff
cavaliere athl x has a great neck
tutorial may you could link to that's
where I learned it over time I worked up
to from a 10 pound plat I I can do five
or six reps on each side with a 45b
plate you're kidding me you put a 45
that's 20 kilos for the anglicans so
I'll do that and I don't say that to be
tough or anything but the idea for me is
to just have a really strong um neck so
that also for pressing movements and
pulling movements you'll get much
stronger there well listen the bar has
now been set for the fledgling huberman
husbands out there they know that the
neck training is a important part black
shirt neck training bit of BS well well
the black TR well to be clear and women
should probably train their neck as well
but lighter you know um for aesthetic
reasons um and if they want to have a
bigger neck they can do that but I think
most women don't want their neck this is
one muscle er group that does tend to
grow pretty quickly um is that right it
does it does and and then the other
thing and this looks ridiculous but that
Fighters know it's very useful is that
there's the kiss the sky thing where
they'll actually look up and you know
and you'll feel it in the deeper muscles
of the neck wow so that kind of thing is
again you know some people use a towel
for this stuff if they don't have access
to weights but neck workor is really key
just like ABW work is key just like
lower back work is key just like tib
work is key knees over toes guy you know
love his content Ben's amazing so these
smaller muscle groups are not going to
be the main stay of any workout but they
become so important when you're thinking
about longevity because they are the
muscle groups that tend to cause if not
train shin splints kink in the neck the
kink in the neck is obviously uh not a
technical term but pain in the neck the
turning in the shower after doing heavy
pressing and then like you're out your
neck you can't turn your head the lower
back pain sciatica often lower spine
stabilization issues I I really think
Jeff Cavalier has some of the best zeroc
cost content on this that's uh I've
followed his content for years and you
know if you put in for instance sciatic
a low back pain he has diagnostic tools
there that really help you establish
whether or not it's truly lower back
pain or it's a medial glute issue and
gives you the proper things to do and
neck is just one piece of the equation
getting back to huberman husbands um the
yeah I chuckled the first time I saw it
I I think it was a little frustrating to
me because I thought wait there are a
lot of women that do these protocols too
our Protocols are Mo we have had some
male hormone Health episodes some female
hormone Health episodes but in general
we're just talking about stuff that's
applicable to everybody but listen um I
don't control the internet um I don't
make the rules out there and you know
and then traditional media Amplified the
huberman husbands piece through a couple
of articles and the next thing you know
that that's the black shirt I should
just say um is because uh I try and as
we've talked about before I don't want T
My Tattoos to distract I got a lot of
them um I want to focus on content and
teaching and people hearing the content
and um and the black shirt is something
I did long before I had a podcast that's
because the great Joe Strummer singer
for The Clash mcolo wore a black
button-down shirt while he would do full
shows and he would be soaking wet it was
like the punkest thing I ever saw that
he was like doing full show was like
belting it out and in long sleeve black
shirt and he was just literally the
shirt was like stuck to his body and I
was just saying like not only is he an
amazing humanitarian writer poet singer
for The Clash creative you miss him he's
gone but he's still here through music
right as they say and he um you know
he's just so Punk he's just up there in
his 40s or late 40s and and soaking wet
and I'm thinking like that guy like he's
got he's got it figured out I'm you know
so anyway and I like the black shirt
what say we'll get back to talking to
Andrew in one minute but first I need to
tell you about ag1 ag1 is a product that
I've been using every single day for
over three years now Dr huberman himself
is a massive fan because it is the most
comprehensive foundational daily
nutrition supplement on the market my
digestion is so much better since I've
started using ag1 and I genuinely can't
remember what life used to be like but
when I stop using it I do not like the
way that my body feels since 2010 ag1
has led the foundational nutrition
Revolution continually refining their
formula to create better smarter ways to
elevate your health ag1 is the
supplement I trust to provide the
support that my body needs every single
day and that's why they've been a
partner for so long if you want to take
ownership of your health it starts with
ag1 you can get all of this with your
first purchase a free your supply of
vitamin D five free travel packs free
pots shakers and that 90-day money back
guarantee by going to the link in the
description below or heading to drink
a1.com
wisdom that's drink a1.com
wisdom How concerned do you think we
should be about vaping spoke about
alcohol it seems like there's this uh
big Vape is on Netflix at the moment
it's uh a documentary about the rise of
Jewel and um I'm only one episode in but
it seems like vaping is now catching an
awful lot of attention what how
concerned do you think we should be
about vaping yeah I'm sorry I'm just
taking a note here I take notes during
our podcast um highly intense it totally
makes sense um just the things I can go
back to um we should be very concerned
so when it comes to smoking or vaping
there's the thing that's being consumed
the the thing that people are trying to
bring put in their bloodstream nicotine
cannabis Etc and let's just set those
aside I've done episodes on nicotine and
cannabis and um they have their
application they also have their
problems vaping is terrible because of
the other chemicals that delivers to the
lungs it's also very clear and we
haven't released this episode yet but I
talked to a female hormone doc from
Austin Natalie Crawford OBGYN you know
vaping is associated with disruptions in
egg health and what they call Egg
quality can create certain mutations in
eggs um and serious endocrine issues in
women okay um personally I find it
disgusting like I just find it like I
don't do it but when I see people vaping
like to me and listen I used to when
growing up I I I quit smoking a long
time ago but I used to smoke a bit of
nicotine growing up remember I was I was
a wild one but that's not why I did it I
just I you know nicotine works for me as
a drug and I don't do it anymore um but
vaping is so addictive it's a mutagen it
mutates the genes of cells it mutates
the genes of rapidly dividing cells most
so breast cancers ovarian cancers egg
quality you know sperm are constantly
turning over so you know people always
say no well I Vape all the time and I
got so and so pregnant or whatever you
know when say have a perfectly healthy
kid that kid might have been much
healthier and also the kid's not grown
up yet like introducing me to the kid
later I wish for that kid I pray for
them but um that they're healthy as can
be but it is so clear that you're
introducing a t a laundry list of toxins
to the lungs and they're getting into
the bloodstream and there are a number
of them that cross the blood brain brain
barrier and once they cross the blood
brain barrier those neurons by virtue of
the fact that neurons don't turn over
across the lifespan you born with the
ones you're going to die with you might
add a few across your lifespan but
you're mostly born with the ones that
you're going to die with well they're
going to Harbor those chemicals and
those particulates and you know yes our
we have grandparents that smoked and
lived to be 90 but you know those are
generally the outliers so I I can't find
one good reason why people should Vape
if they if people want nicotine in their
system that badly and here I'm
recommending that they would be much
better off relying on a tro or a patch y
um or even toothpicks or or you know or
injectable I know people I'm not going
to out any inject nicotine oh I'm not
going to out anyone here but I I know um
people in our podcast community that
rely on nicotine injections for mental
Clarity that is so hardcore yeah I don't
it it causes um elevation in blood
pressure it causes um basoc constriction
but it also will robustly increase focus
and attention any
will tell you maining ni you're starting
to see some companies that offer things
like NAD infusions also offer
subcutaneous or or um nicotine
injections going back to or patch or gum
yeah smoking for a very long time
everyone knows huge Campaign which I
think was pretty effective actually at
kind of discouraging people from smoking
or at least making them aware about the
do do you remember how they got kids to
stop smoking they told them for years it
was bad for their health that didn't
work they told them uh
that it was putting money in the pockets
of these like uh of like these old
cackling white guys that were like
rubbing their hands in the in up in the
boardroom and making a ton of money and
then it became the rebellious thing to
quit smoking that was the effective
campaign I I think about this all the
time that there was a big push to uh
both disincentivize and make more
different smoke uh make more difficult
smoking you got to go outside there's
the smoking area I remember I worked in
clubs for one year before the smoking
Band came in yeah in the UK and then
people had to go outside you know just
friction friction friction all the way
down and then vaping came in and vaping
is way more enjoyable of an experience
than smoking ever was you you can have a
higher dose of nicotine that tastes you
know enjoyable bubblegum flavor and
raspberry unicorn dust and whatever
whatever I don't know uh and it's not
going to stink the house out you know
you don't have any of the externalities
of that so I wonder whether we have
ended up in a net benefit or net cost
for public health from switching from
smoking to vaping yeah there's an analog
here with you know katum and opioids you
know if you really want to we just got
to put ourselves under attack by even
bringing up the topic but I did it
intentionally
um you know there are things like
smoking and opioid addiction which are
it's unequivocal it's just terrible
right it crushes lives destroys lives um
yes there are those rare individuals who
smok their whole life lived into their
90s and okay but they are outliers um so
the question is did is vaping allowing
fewer people to smoke and therefore
improving their health maybe if they're
hellbent on getting that nicotine or
cannabis into their system and they're
CH opting not to smoke and they're going
to vape instead then maybe we have to be
objective and say okay if they are
absolutely intent on on getting it in
through some inhalation device vaping is
probably better but we don't know that
for sure we actually don't know that and
then since I brought it up and I really
put the Target on myself with this one
you know I I did a post about katom
which is over the counter um people will
say it's not an opioid it Taps the
opioid system it Taps other systems as
well and a number of people have indeed
um managed to get themselves off of
opioids using katum as a bit of a bridge
kind of like the methadone heroin thing
um but the katum advocacy groups are
really growing strong right now because
um there is the possibility that katom
will be made illegal in the not too
distant future and there is the reality
that some people who were never opioid
addicts have taken katum and then get
addicted to katum and then people start
arguing is it real addiction is it habit
forming Etc so I think the next year or
so is going to be an interesting time
for dialogue about katum I have a couple
of guests coming on my podcast maybe um
you'll do it as well and I'd love that
if you would there's one thing by the
way folks that's so great about the
podcast space unlike other professions
we love it when one topic or one guest
shows up on multiple podcasts because it
it actually doesn't hurt any of us and
you've sent me in the last few months
you sent me uh Paul Conti uh you've sent
me Rick Rubin it's and everyone's got a
different Flex right the conversation
you're going to have with Rick or Paul
is going to be way different to the one
that I'm going to have which is going to
be way different to the one that Joe's
going to have yeah it's it's a it's a
very different thing than academic
science than journalism of other kinds
the idea it's it's a no scoop they you
know like in Academia or or journalism
they say oh you know who got the scoop
you know that or you got scooped someone
else put it out first and you know in in
um in podcasting it's it's quite the
opposite so I think the katom versus I
me the katum topics can be really
interesting and important to cover but I
think look my vote is to not Vape I
think um I'm just shocked at how many
people vape and first of all it it's
actually be not like cigarette smoking
it's expensive that's not the main
reason people avoid it but it's a
significant expense when you add it up
across the
year it's clearly addictive there's no
question about it it's clearly
detrimental to lung function and then
people like how it makes their brain
feel and they think that if they're
already pretty active Physically Active
then they can offset some of that and
they probably can but um I think in the
next five years or so we're just going
to see a slew of studies showing that
vaping is just bad for us especially for
the developing brain because it's
bringing in at a very rapid rate high
potency nicotine and high potency
cannabis and you know from mon almy's
work and we know my colleague at
Stanford that that the the slope of that
increase in dopamine and epinephrine
adrenaline and acetylcholine is so
important the sharper that slope the
faster the rise the more addictive
potential these compounds have and so
it's so far and away different than the
kind of dopamine or epinephrine or
acetylcholine increase that one sees
with exercise or with cold plunges or
with um with sex or with these other
things or dancing and things you know so
and you know one of course could be
addicted to any of the other things I
just mentioned too but the the potential
for it is is far less than something
like vaping here's my stance on it that
I I understand maybe of the two evils
vaping is less of an evil than
traditional smoking would be but I think
the enjoyability the accessibility the
fact that it isn't as stigmatized all of
that I think that it wouldn't surprise
me if more people are now going to vape
than ever previously smoked and even if
the difference between the two is is
that vaping is better that the total
area under the curve of Public Health
degradation I think that I think that
we've netted a loss overall for vaping
and um you know I see dude I I I go to a
comedy show and I find myself going and
getting an Esco bar before and I'm like
what like why is it it's just habit what
is it it's like a like just a disposable
Vape I do it if I go to a comedy show
and I'm not drinking and I'm tired so
there's like a certain little decision
tree that I go through I'll do it maybe
once a month something like that what do
you vape whatever whatever disposable
unpronouncable hor [__] is available
what is in my friend nitin or cannabis
nicotine nicotine um we're in California
so people talk about cannabis pretty
here um interesting yeah I
think rapid onset of these neurom
modulators in the brain concerns me um
it's just it's just
so different also with with behaviors
you can titrate right you know people
say well video games cause a huge
increase in doing okay fine but you can
limit the total amount of time that you
engage you um I think with with
substances even though you can control
dose or number of of what do they call
it on the it's not going to be like a to
on the vape pen what is it it's going to
be like a like a draw I don't know I
don't know the language vaping laring
cosplay I've got that you know I'm
teaching you everything today everything
I need to know this is good because I'm
going to be able to navigate the
internet fantastic talking about the
internet how worried are you about how
technology is impacting people's ability
to
focus adult ADHD is clearly upon us it's
just clear and so very I'm I'm very
concerned you think that that's induced
or or facilitated or worsened by
technology like tell me tell me what's
going on in the brain If how's
technology able to make such a a
dramatic change yeah I think if we let's
turn it on its head I'm not changing
your question because I don't like when
people do that to me um answer what you
want sometimes I'll ask a question on my
podcast and people will flip they're
like I'm going to give you a different
question answer that one I was like okay
like I'm going to answer your question a
different way the the circuits in the
brain that are required for setting and
maintaining
Focus are inhibited by the process of
deliberately shifting one's Focus over
and over and over throughout the day in
other words um if ever there was a
physical activity that could undermine
your cardiovascular exercise you know
like I mean it turns out not to be the
case but you know there was this idea a
few years ago that if you sit a lot
during the day it doesn't matter how
much you exercise it's not going to make
a difference that's not true right
exercise still helps but we also know
that moving and standing standing and S
you know standing up and sitting down
quite a lot throughout the day getting
as much you know little walks and things
like that is extremely beneficial and
can amplify the already known positive
effects of
exercise okay well when it comes to
focus I mean much of what our school
ring is about growing up is not just the
content that we're taught but our
ability to sit still and pay attention
to keep the body still and to focus to
some extent keep the body still um some
people gesticulate more the Italians and
the you know in certain Arab countries
and things like that and um other people
are far more still and we could get back
to this about body Stillness a little
bit later because there's some emerging
ideas on that that are worth touching on
but the point is that if
one is constantly moving their attention
from one thing to the next it undermines
the stability of all the circuitry in
the brain that's responsible for
prolonged Focus now I partake in social
media so do you but the scroll function
is a practice of Shifting Focus while
maintaining gaze in one location right
normally we would shift focus by looking
here by looking there mean just for try
this for 30 minutes tomorrow folks
listening to this take 30 minutes of
your day and decide you're that you're
only going to exist in the
threedimensional world meaning you're
not going to look at screens for 30
minutes okay obviously screens your
phone has a depth to it but you know
what I'm talking
about you'll notice that your attention
is Shifting all the time you're looking
at brick wall then there's this then
there's you but but it's all harnessed
by some sort of conceptual goal or
physical goal trying to get here finish
a conversation complete an answer to a
question that's all within a tunnel of
of of motivation when you're on your
phone and scrolling and I think
scrolling itself is the major issue when
you're scrolling you're essentially
putting yourself into new context after
new context after new context and the
brain has to adjust to all of that and
the way that the brain works in addition
to controlling heartbeat and anomic
function Etc is think about it sort of
like a like a I I don't want to diss it
but I went I took my sister sister to
see the Harry Potter play u recently in
New York and um while I wasn't a big fan
of the the script at all was this the um
halfblood something what was it called
yeah was the the what is it the like the
cursed child yeah yeah yeah me me Jordan
Peterson and Douglas Murray got thrown
out nearly got thrown out of that during
coid I've got to tell you the story once
you're done it's one of the phenomenal
thing that I saw so you went to go and
see it I my sister likes theater and we
go to New York each year for her
birthday and um I took her to this show
um and I wasn't a big fan of the script
to be honest um I only read one of the
Harry Potter books liked it but then
abandoned it but she she really likes
the Harry Potter stories um I wasn't a
fan of the script that's just my
uninformed opinion but the effects were
spectacular okay and one of the things
that occurred to me they had this
Library there where the books are alive
and as I was watching this I realized
that's very much how the brain works
that for instance when you walk into a
room it's a new context and it would be
the same as if you were walking through
a library and let's say you you go to a
um soccer European football game and you
sit down and all of a sudden the your
brain calls up all these books about
European soccer and your favorite team
is right there and then you open that
and then all of a sudden um you're
looking at that something about your
favorite team what's your favorite team
Newcastle Newcastle okay and then with
unbeknownst to you unbeknownst to you
this is the important part the books all
around you not the one you're looking at
are now changing to the competitors and
the history of that team but also who's
the um the directly antagonistic rival
team sundland Su Sunderland Sunderland
okay there it is
okay so that's the way the brain works
it's calling up context so that it makes
it very easy to flp to a discussion
about a particular rivalry in a
particular year in a particular match in
a particular point and player that's
focus focus is not about maintaining a
single tunnel of cognition focus is
about calling to mind all these
additional contextually relevant batches
of information that you might need and
you know the reason I the analogy of the
Harry
Potter library is that it's a dynamic
Library so the moment we're done here
and we walk out yes some of the the
books so to speak of the of this
conversation will linger with us but
whatever we're focused on next whatever
goal directed Behavior we have making it
to dinner or through traffic or wherever
we're going will call up a new library
now some people might say well duh of
course it works that way but it's not
duh because it's very Dynamic now social
media is the opposite of that it's one
library next account another Library
next account another library next
account another Library another Library
another library and the brain is calling
up all these different libraries in
Rapid succession so when I look like
I'll be honest the the selected choice
of things to click on tells me a lot
about what I've been clicking on right
that I mean obviously the algorithm is
telling I confess and I'm really
embarrassed to say but not so
embarrassed that I won't reveal that
what I find now on that gallery of
things to select are street fights so
beat down
and really adorable strange animals or
cute animals I love the Flora and Fa
duality of Andrew hberman right and not
the cppy bar like if ever there was an
uninteresting animal it's the cppy bar
however yes the raccoon accounts are
delightful to me the the the nature is
metal account is very cool that there's
an extensive community of capy bar
enthusiasts on Instagram which you're a
member of no I I've actively avoided
capy bar
um you're a big octopus guy though I
like seop pods I like cuttlefish my lab
used to work on cuttlefish um and
octopus is um octop and octopuses it's
octopuses I've been taught for so long
that it's octopus it's octopuses and and
actually this is the most hang on this
is gonna kill me because there was a
meme about this because we did a live
okay so I know too much about this
because I used to my lab used to work on
seop pods which are one they're which
are in the category of mollusk include
cuttlefish um um and octopuses and so
it's octopuses is the correct plural and
this is the this is the most like
groundbreaking piece of information that
we've got so far today moreover the
great Oliver Sachs who's now
unfortunately dead is a a neurologist
and popular writer about the brain
function the man who mistook his wife
for his hat Etc a real hero of mine um
talked about this that you know it's
also
platypuses and that he wrote about you
can look this up he wrote about
traveling to Australia and then going to
the far north where they have a breeding
program to reestablish the platypuses
and that the location of the bleeding
the breeding program excuse me is um
literally the plat
puser wow yeah yeah Oliver Sachs wrote
about this so I've long been interested
in the Platypus as an interesting animal
they're very interest octop octopus
octopuses um yeah that's okay you know
many it's it's a revolution so does that
mean that the plural is the of or that
the location where they breed octopuses
is the
octopusy I hope so okay I want to go
there yeah well according to Oliver
Sachs this is the correct nomenclature
and he's the neurologist expert in
seapods so we can return to this at some
point um I'm sure people will put in the
comments where we're right where we're
wrong either way they will have gone out
and researched and learned and that's
what the that's what we're here for I
want to show you I want to show you this
video um we can put it up on the screen
just press play on the middle of that
and uh and let me know what you think
right so the for those listening who
aren't watching this isn't image of a
kid flipping back and forth between a
iPad and a phone
um with Incredible dexterity this is a
family out to dinner and the kids are
watching screens there's another kid
without any phone in his hands crying um
attempting to swipe the phone that is
not in his hand as if um as if
scratching at a an itch but not
successfully and a kid actually tapping
a screen in their sleep yeah yes this
indeed we are in the thank you um what
do you think's going on though yeah um
and thanks for getting me out of the
animal fights conversation um the uh
what's happening is very clear which is
that you know the brain the human brain
is an incredible organ because it's a
map of our experience it has certain
parts that are hardwired that govern our
heart rate and control of our heart rate
control of our breathing um immune uh
certain immune functions and on and on
but then a vast percentage of our of the
human brain is is open Real Estate that
um is designated as one function or
another depending on what happens to you
during development so we know this for
sure my scientific great-grandparents
won the Nobel Prize for this David Hub
and Tor and weasel that what you see
during development really between the
ages of birth and about age 14 mainly
but certainly extending longer creates a
set of modules or Maps within the brain
that allow you to predict what's going
to happen in the future so if kids are
growing up doing a lot of swiping
Behavior this remember we're in the
first time in human history where people
have written with their thumbs also
right texting um there are entirely
different maps of how language is
encoded uh motor I should say how motor
functions and language interact um you
know in the past meaning for tens of
thousands of years if not longer
gesticulating Accord and speech and
grunting and shouting and pointing it's
one of the primary modes of
communication it's not surprising
therefore that the representation of the
hands and the digits which is a nerd
speak for fingers
is right next to the areas of the brain
they're responsible for generating
language and speech and language so we
now have
the ability to speak with our thumbs so
so to speak no pun intended by texting
we now have the ability to see many
different contextual Landscapes as we
talked about before by swiping typically
up sometimes down typically up right so
the upswipe is become you know as uh
perhaps as hard not as mapped into the
brain as the wave hi you what do you say
to babies you know hi people try and get
their attention get them to go wied
smile how you know they do peek-aboo
these kind of people been doing this for
a very long time now the swipe function
is one of the ways in which human beings
engage in the world it's almost it's not
as fundamental as opening one's mouth to
eat but it's pretty close so the the
brain has just adapted to this but
there's real estate set aside for
whatever your experience was and so what
you're seeing there is just kids very
adapt at doing this because it's always
a trade-off hubal visel in part won the
Nobel Prize for showing that
plasticity of the brain mapping of the
brain for one particular sensory
experience or function say swiping or
the ability to switch back and forth
between multiple screens is always
always at the expense of some other
potential function you can't do
everything so when children are
inculcating that particular habit there
is the Thomas Soul quote like there are
no Solutions only tradeoffs right uh
yeah I I
think I've got written on my whiteboard
on my fridge at the moment uh the five
most common deathbed regrets and it's
things like I wish that I'd not worked
as much I wish I'd let myself be happy I
wish I'd stayed in touch with my friends
um it will be unbelievably surprising to
me if in 40 years time I wish I'd spent
less time on my phone isn't on there I
would
bet pretty much everything that I have
that that that would probably appear on
average on people's five top deathbed
regrets I wish I'd spent less time on my
phone and we can see this happening in
front of us and the best way that you
can tell that this is going to continue
to happen is that you can reflect on
what you did over the last week and one
of the most common things that you wish
that you'd done less of over the last
week was shouldn't I I got I got
captured I I did a couple of YouTube
holes or Tik Tok Scrolls or Instagram
whatevers and you know that this is
happening in the micro spread that
across a lifetime you know I think that
very much we're going to look back at
this and hopefully there is some kind of
solution maybe it's neuralink maybe you
know we have a way that we can kind of
ethically engage with technology and get
the communication and the stimulation
and the exploration of different ideas
and communities uh but yeah right now
kind of feels a little bit like um maybe
a little bit like when cigarettes first
came out like your doctor smokes camels
you know like we didn't nobody knew what
the bad effects of this were they didn't
know longterm what it was going to cause
and dude that video I really wanted to
show it to you because you T me I I was
I think correctly or
incorrectly categorizing people's phone
use as an addiction and I think that you
said it's much more like a compulsion
right and that is a child that's asleep
or nearly
asleep prot like compulsively scrolling
through that film yeah because a
compulsion uh does not the ex an
obsession is mental this is a classic
definition of compulsion is a behavior
but the
compulsion in classic OCD doesn't
relieve the obsession it actually
exacerbates it the payoff lack of so
you're you're not it's sort of like an
itch that you scratch and it just get it
itches more right and there is something
like that with social I don't want to
say social media but with phone
scrolling now that said I mean you know
you know of my waking hours most of it
is
spent foraging for organizing or
dispersing information and much of that
is done on the phone or computer but I
do read books you know hard books uh
meaning physical books I brought you one
today thank you um I like audio books
too I I listen to a lot of podcasts I
watch your YouTube videos so I learn
when I'm on the internet but yeah
occasionally it's the uh you know well I
learned from nature is metal but but but
I haven't learned anything from the
raccoon post um nothing of substance
anyway here's the that they're very like
they're very like cute and very um they
do that thing when they scoop scoop food
up like this and they they wash food in
my pool now I moved to a place I'm
renting a place that has a pool I've
never had a pool before I've
skateboarding a lot of empty pools but
I've never had one that had water in it
so and they come through in the night
it's raccoon Olympics in the middle of
the night and they're coming through
they make a ton of noise and then
they're washing their food and it's
pretty cute the first time you see it
but once they wake you up the third or
fourth time then racco you're trying to
yeah so you know I haven't learned much
from that uh from the raccoon videos
certainly the fight videos haven't
really taught me anything about
self-defense or or anything useful
except how you know just kind of cruel
people can be so I'm trying to change
the algorithm by by clicking on other
things but it seems pretty slow to
change I got to tell you this it's got
me on I've never been into Star Wars
I've seen some of the movies or whatever
but I've never been into it for some
reason it started delivering me short
content about Star Wars law like who
would have won between Darth Vader and
dark Maul and all who was more powerful
as a Jedi master and all this stuff and
I've never been interested in this and
yet it's created in me the desire to
actually be like well yeah like would
Master Yoda have
won however many eons ago if he was at
full power when the the the Sith was and
I don't even know what I'm talking about
but it's like created in me this thing
the interesting thing that you're
talking about there is that there's
um when you're foraging you spend enough
time on the internet and you do find
something that gives you that oh wow I
never knew about about that before and
it's that um sort of needle in a hay
stack that you're looking through and
that trigger of wow I found so I can
talk about it on a podcast this is
really interesting to me that is the
carrot I think that gets dangled for for
very many people who want to feel better
about their social media use and think
well okay yeah you know I wasted 90
minutes but I did get that thing out of
it I read that substack post or I found
this new person that I really care about
uh you know the variable schedule reward
of uh intellectual satisfaction is also
in there right it's not just the shock
sure it's not just the cute yeah for me
is that you know PubMed a library of the
only guy who thinks that PubMed is
variable schedule reward I remember when
PubMed first came out as as a like a
very searchable dat database and and
some of the journals later became
electronic and now they're all available
electronic and I could not believe I was
so excited cuz I used to go to the
library and I have to pay with put money
on the card and Rock copy and stuff but
also in the library I love libraries and
I'd spend so much time when I was a a
student and graduate student and you'd
find something and it was like I'd look
around like did anyone like did you see
that did you see that but since I was a
little kid I was discovering stuff in
books and then talking about it to
everybody even if they didn't want to
here and so I was professing from a
young age in class on Mondays and things
so so for me it's hardwired into my
system by now and I think that I I do
think that social media holds certain
gems I think we're think talking about
like mining for gems of social
interaction too you know I've gotten to
know some people through social media
where it's really enriched my life I've
reconnected with some people yep and
it's really enriched my life it's
allowed me to connect the dots um going
backward in ways I hadn't anticipated
and I think going forward if you're
asking about the kids in the video that
you showed me or you're talking about
adults or anyone it's the the the
success is largely going to be
determined by who has the most
self-discipline I really do now it's
always been the case but I don't think
it's ever been the case to the extent
that it is now so this is why I'm such a
fan of taking some space from all action
this is actually something I learned
from Rick Ruben um you know I'm
fortunate to call him a close friend we
we communicate pretty much every day and
I went and spent a week with him abroad
this summer it was the worst time to
travel and I decided to go over to where
he was in Europe and just spend the week
with him we had no plan and um uh first
of all on the way over there there was
nothing to watch on the plane but there
was this Tom Petty documentary I turn it
on I'm not a huge Tom Petty fan but it
was interesting enough and then rck Rick
is in the documentary and he's in the
documentary lying down doing the
interview typical like typical meaning
unusual for most people typical because
it's unusual for Rick to be lying down
um and I thought okay so get there I I
know his family well and I love them and
and it was really wonderful it was
beautiful it's a beautiful part of
Europe but but you know I noticed so we
had this habit of of we would tread
water in the pool and listen to podcasts
in the morning um and there's a
wonderful podcast by the way that uh we
should all be aware of I think is a
history of rock and roll in 500 songs by
Andrew hickey super nerdy it's like a
getting a like a graduate degree in rock
and roll it talks about the music but
also what's happening in like organized
crime how it impacted record sales very
contextual very cool I'm very into that
lately and I'm in and this show on
Netflix have you seen Spy Ops yes which
is very good right because it's not just
like shoot them up typee stuff it's it's
really about how spy operations uh let
me put it this way it can teach you a
lot about history International history
and and um geopolitical history um so um
I go over there and we do some Treading
Water listening to um podcasts I learn
about this history of of rock and roll
and 500 songs podcasts um we talk about
a little bit and then I noticed that you
know Rick has a practice hope he doesn't
mind me sharing this um because I'm
about to um you know Rick has a practice
he has many practices but one of them is
he'll spend a good amount of time you
know just sitting and thinking or lying
down and thinking and I it didn't occur
to me at the time
but later after I returned I thought
back to our first guest episode of my
podcast I host a guy named Carl di Roth
who's probably the the finest
bioengineer on the planet he's also a
fully active clinician psychiatrist he's
got five children he's these phenoms you
know that seems to be able to do
everything he's a true genius um he went
to school with medical school with
petera and Paul kti they were all in the
same class yeah um and I know him very
well he's a colleague of mine at
Stanford and um and everyone knows he's
he's a super he's a super he's like the
Michael Jordan of Neuroscience um except
he's still active um and that is not a
statement about personality just in
terms of of successful hit rate and Carl
described a practice that he does after
he puts his kids to sleep s of where he
sits deliberately sits completely still
and forces himself to think in complete
sentences and this set off a light in my
head when I realize Rick does a form of
this and Carl does a form of this if you
read the new Elon Musk book they talk
about Elon doing a form of this the
Great Richard Fineman physicist Nobel
Prize winner talked about going into
flotation tanks and doing a form of this
Einstein did a form of this so what are
we talking about so I'm a neuroscientist
but I'm certainly not as smart as of
those
guys what we're talking about is body
still mind active now I've become in
increasingly curious about psychedelic
therapies um one of which is and by the
way only in a clinical context Etc
legality Etc not in kids Etc but the
practice is essentially um macro doil
oybin but with the eye mask on
completely still mind very active Okay
contract that to a different Behavior SL
protocol that I'm very familiar with
which is I like to do long runs or rucks
on Sunday body very active mind not
directed at anything in particular
sometimes I'll do it without a book or
podcast sometimes I do it with a
combination of
both many people talk about swimming or
in the shower or um cycling some sort of
rhythmic movement drumming the great Joe
Strummer was really big on campfires he
you know I was going to mention this
earlier but I'll mention it now that as
an alternative to alcohol consumption
get your friends together around a fire
by the way the Fire Light the light from
fire does not disrupt the Circadian
system this has actually been shown
candle light Moonlight fire light as
bright as it is it's just very low Lux
so that's where great things happen
independent of alcohol right around a
campfire as it goes way back in our
lineage so there these two states of
mind and body that I find fascinating to
the point of being intriguing to the
point of having modified what I do now
because they the they're the inverse of
one another body completely still or
close to completely still mind very
active could be with cybin but that's
not the protocol I'm recommending I'm
talking about some very very smart
extremely accomplished people who all
did the same thing the other is body
very active mind isn't still but is not
deliberately um channeled to any
particular linear kind of story or
something like
that there's a state in sleep where our
body is literally paralyzed and the
brain is extremely active it's called
rapid eye movement sleep so I'm s of
raising a flag for this potential
protocol practice I don't have any
peer-reviewed science to support what
I'm about to say but I have enough
examples of extremely accomplished
people now uh in front of me to realize
that there's something special about
divorcing mind and body
function temporarily deliberately
sitting there and just thinking and
recently I had a conversation with the
Great Paul kti and the addition of the
words the great in front of him are
appropriate here he's I I believe based
on my observation of his clinical work
and an uh intellectual Acumen that he's
the finest psychiatrist of our age
clearly integrating from so many
backgrounds has worked with a ton of
interesting people coming on the podcast
in December amazing I and he's just
phenomenal right um not just about
trauma but about everything personality
typees narcissism gaslighting I mean
people throw those terms around like
crazy paa will tell you what it actually
means okay what those terms actually
mean
but the ability to think and to access
the unconscious Paul refers to the
unconscious as the supercomputer of the
brain for the the unconscious mind and
the conscious mind are always in a
dialogue but here's the theory here's
the the hypothesis that when we bring
our body into states of Stillness in REM
sleep in these deliberate states that I
just described that these other people
actively engage in and have for a long
time that the unconscious mind can start
to take over a larger percentage of that
conversation and we have access to new
ideas new ways of structuring thought
Etc and I don't think one requires
psilocybin to do it but I do think that
is one Avenue into it reliable um that's
reliable it also carries certain hazards
right uh because it's it's like being
put on a mental rocket ship to some
extent it's not like DMT but um very
little control over where one's
cognition goes although there is some in
there um anyway I just wanted to throw
this up on the wall because it's always
fun to talk about new things and kind of
what's coming what I think is coming
next I think if I were to make a
prediction I think in the next two years
you're not just going to hear about
meditation non-sleep deep rest um
something I'm a big fan of Yoga Nidra
hypnosis but also whatever we want to
call this you'll probably come up with a
better name than I can body still mind
active states to access different
aspects of our unconscious and cognition
and I must say that we do this with the
phone sorry I just uh because I realized
you were about to say something and when
you speak you say interesting things and
I learned cosplay laring Lear don't put
those ones as the most interesting no
you say many there's no well in terms of
new terms new terms yeah yeah Newcastle
yeah Sunland sorry those was one of the
most Concepts I but I'm learning is the
point I wasn't I wasn't being sarcastic
um that when you we sit and we're just
scrolling yeah we're we're we're more or
less body still mind active but guess
what none of it's coming from within
it's all coming from the outside so
whether or not it's Sil cybin in the eye
mask or or Carl sitting there eyes
closed deliberately still thinking or
Fineman in the in the salt equilibration
chamber you know the the float
floatation tank or or Rick lying there
thinking whatever it is he happens to be
thinking whatever amazing album he's
going to now you know help produce um or
Einstein I
mean you know we can think of the phone
and the scrolling as as lending itself
to less ability to focus in ADH but just
the real crime the real insult to
humanity for me the real cost is what
about all the creative imagination of
things that come from inside that could
be generated by by people in that time
so I I'm I've started doing a practice
of 20 minutes a day of just sitting and
eyes closed typically sometimes it's
right as I wake up but usually it's not
and just trying to think about certain
topics and hold those topics in a kind
of a linear way or sometimes just
letting stuff geyser up anyway um some
people might think of this as like
completely um wacko woo uh new Agy stuff
but the list of names I I read off there
people that do that and have been doing
this for a long time and attribute this
practice as one of the major sources of
their best ideas is a a non-trivial list
when I think about that there's a few
different ways that are slightly similar
uh the number of people who've had great
ideas whilst walking and attribute an
awful lot of their success to walking
and thinking I'm that you're talking
body still mind active but it's like
body mostly still it's not exactly like
or perhaps there is a unique way to
access this too maybe it's a different
channel to a different brain State maybe
it's a different channel to the same
brain State like I love doing long rocks
and long runs on Sunday that's my goal
on Sunday get out as much as possible
into the nature and just move in some
sort of repetitive way like a me author
on a ruck sack cuz petera got me into
that um sometimes it's with other people
sometimes alone sometimes I listen to a
podcast sometimes I don't
sometimes in audio book sometimes I
don't but something about about motor
repetition uh so this is not sets and
Reps this is not restacking the pl this
is you know minimum amount of cognition
required freeing up mental space to do
other things yeah could be on the row so
again I think different people will do
it differently I've been hanging around
with a lot of musicians lately um I've
become good friends with one of my
favorite musicians songwriters Tim
Armstrong lead singer for rancid
transplants he and Travis Barker did
transplants and you know it's it um and
you know it's clear that musicians
especially drummers but other musicians
well they're always in a rhythm in their
head there actually Tim and I the other
day we we went someplace and we walked
out he's like did you hear that like did
you hear what he's like you didn't hear
that I was like well he's like you know
they had the news on and the radio on
and this you know he's so tuned into the
audio environment I'm not right I'm not
that audio um oriented more visually
oriented but you know people who have an
internal Rhythm that they're they're
they're they're noodling on something in
their head I mean this is this is the
substrate of creative work right and I
and again the phone isn't evil but the
moment you're taking in sensory input
from that includes things that have
already been creative uh excuse me
created you're yeah you could argue that
those are the macronutrients that you're
going to combine for your own creative
thing the gems in the internet so
studies scientific studies for me or
interesting things on YouTube but
there's also just the raw materials of
creative work that come from limiting
sensory inut and just going inside self
generating it yes so I've been
thinking one of the things that people
want a lot more of I think is focus
attention productivity as someone who
values the work output that you do
productivity as a word is quite
nefarious quite nebulous quite sort of
ephemeral how have you come to think
about the concept of productivity and
its constituent Parts have you got any
tools any Strate IES tactics that you
use to kind of drop yourself into a
productive State and stay there yeah so
I do all the things that I um profess um
you know at the level of the basics
morning sunlight non-sleep deep rest if
I didn't get enough sleep um
physiological size when I need to bring
my level of autonomic arousal AKA stress
down these are all things I've talked
about um three days a week of
cardiovascular training three days a
week of resistance training one day a
week of deliberate cold deliberate heat
minimum uh usually on the day after
after leg day um I do all that stuff um
and it creates a structure and yes it
takes some time and a lot of that stuff
can be compin combined excuse me with
consumption of podcasts and audiobooks
at the same time and social time um but
for me the process of writing and I'm
working on a book now but also just the
creative process has been greatly
enhanced and productivity overall by
setting in this 20 minute period where I
force myself to just stop and have
deliberate thought that are within a
single context I don't let my mind
wander so it's very different than maybe
the psilocybin Journey where feels it
sounds to me a little bit like active
meditation or kind of like narrative
meditation in a way you know you're
forcing your mind to come back to the
you're not just allowing yourself to
Branch off onto a current onto a new
thought okay here I am this is the trunk
of the tree and I'm going to try and
follow this trunk as high as I can uh
what about you know you're sitting down
at the desk you have the research to do
the emails to write the whatever what
have you got Tac ially in terms of a
priming or a structure for that specific
situation yeah I use handwritten sticky
notes and I'll put the thing that I'm
supposed to do and I'll keep looking at
it because I'm amazed at how often my
mind will flp to other things it's like
oh I have to transfer some money as
somebody that I owe them or I have to
pay that bill or I have to I mean the
number of excuses that leap to mind is
outrageous for everybody unless we're
under deadline fear or extremely rare
but you know High motivational state
because we just simply love it so I give
myself five minutes or so to break into
the work or 5 to 10 minutes I don't
expect full focus in that first 5 to 10
minutes but here's what I tell myself
because I know from 30 plus years of
experience the feeling that I'm going to
get after I complete something having
like really had to push against the
grain to force my attention back to that
thing the feeling of having accomplished
even a you know one hour bout of work is
so incredibly rewarding for me and the
feeling of having done BAS basically
nothing is such an
incredible sense of disappointment and
lack of life like such a like Vitality
drain for me um I'm not as hard on
myself as I gather some people out there
are like David Goggins talks about his
selft talk and how he can be very hard
on himself at times but U mine isn't
like that but I know how great it's
going to feel when I get to the so
you're projecting forward the reward
that you're going to feel to bring that
into the now that's very smart I've got
written on my other I've got two uh two
fridge whiteboards uh the other is what
would you tomorrow want you today to do
right and that to me is
the it's like a Panacea for avoiding bad
decisions M uh you know because you live
with the story that you tell yourself
about the decision for way longer than
the enjoyment or lack of of the decision
there is a cookie on the table I
promised myself I wouldn't eat it and I
make a decision about whether whether or
not I eat the cookie there is either
enjoyment or reward enjoyment in eating
it or reward of uh satisfaction of
discipline for not eating it that
happens now but what's really important
is the story that I tell myself tomorrow
about being the sort of person that is
an cookie eater or is not a cookie eater
and I think that that framing that we
place around the present moment largely
determines our experience of it and I
find myself trying to live for future
Chris more and the more I do that the
better that my life seems to get there
are very few situations in which I make
a decision today that I tomorrow would
have wanted me to that turn out to be
the wrong decision and um that
projecting forward how am I going to
feel in future this is difficult now uh
uh Rick Hansen you know neurons that
fire together why together like can you
sit with some of the satisfaction after
you've done something that's good can
you maybe even bring that forward a
little bit give yourself a little oh
yeah that's how it's going to do uh yeah
one other thing that I've just been so
fascinated by recently uh you have been
a big proponent and I think have really
help people in getting sunlight in the
eyes early on let's get ourselves
outside walk I think you taught me about
the lateral eye movement can
downregulate the amigdala response all
stuff that I'd found on my own just
through doing a morning walk and then
again like with the alcohol thing gets
legitimated through the science you know
it's something that I did found it
myself and then I'm like ah this wasn't
just Bro Science or some weird quot of
my physiology this was actually
something that can be shown up in the
literature too ran Doris from the flow
research Collective has the flow morning
routine have you seen this from him I
haven't but I know ran R's an absolute
Monster uh his morning routine developed
with Steven Cotler to get yourself into
flow specifically for deep work and
writing is to begin working within 90
seconds of waking because the state of
flow and the state of sleep are not far
away away from each other in terms of
brain frequency Delta and Theta there
sort of Lial State yeah I I haven't seen
that yet but I I'll check it out
I I am a big believer in the moment you
wake up if you were dreaming keep your
eyes closed and keep your body
completely still also similar if you
wake up from a nightmare and you don't
and you want to forget about that
nightmare you need to move your body
there's something about body movement
that discards the prior cognitive map
it's like it clears the library we're
talking about the the dynamic Harry
potterish Library I don't want to give
too much credit Harry Potter certainly
not to that play but one thing that I'll
I'll just about the productivity piece
before um reflect on this further the um
because something you said really really
struck a chord with me you know I can
project to the Future me but that's not
exactly how I do it what I'm I just know
because I'm so familiar with it the
feeling that I get having actually
accomplished some small percentage to
large percentage of what I was set out
to do feels so unbelievably rewarding to
me and I know that it also enhances the
social interactions I'll have it's like
a feeling of self-satisfaction that
transcends to an ability to show up with
more clarity of mind I'm one of the the
problems for me in terms of productivity
is I'm very strongly affiliative I'm
very fortunate to have a lot of close
friends so if I get a text message from
someone I feel compelled to write them
back not out of responsibility because
if it's someone I'm close with I love
that person like I love my family but I
I love my friends I love my co-workers
colleagues at the podcast I mean it's it
extends and this has to do with my
upbringing the fact that my
non-biological family became my family
before I sort of reconnected with my
actual family in a really deep way but
um the one exception being my sister and
I were were were you know tight tight uh
the whole time but that for me you know
a text coming isn't isn't a distraction
like that's the that's the good stuff in
life that's one of the reasons I'm there
so I have this practice sometimes of
imagining that my um my crew right as
the kids say were I'm pretty cruded up
these days um which is great because it
wasn't always the case they want me to
like forage off to where I need to go
and collect the gems and come up with
the ideas that are going to be the next
post the next podcast the next
scientific study they want that I tell
myself they want that for me like
they're cheering me on because I know
I'm cheering them on some are musicians
some do other things um I'm cheering
them on I want them to know like I'm
here and I want you to go get the stuff
and do your thing and so I imagine that
they're doing that for me and I turn my
phones off and there's some anxiety in
doing that I'll put it in the car
sometimes because it's not that I'm I
need to neurotically check the phone
because I don't feel safe if I don't
hear from them like I love these people
and I don't want them to feel as if I'm
not available that's really how it is
for me but I know that and I think uh
someone said it and I forget the quote
so forgive me but you know if you're
going to create anything of value in
this life you're going even if it's with
other people you're going to have to be
willing to to be on your own for a bit
to forge on your own to take walks alone
and then return to people to your tribe
so to speak and share with them what
you've learned or maybe even just show
up with whatever energy shift has
occurred while you were off um doing
your thing and so you know the phones
the phones are a wonderful tool but I
think over the years I I lost the
ability to uh be truly on my own and
dropped into work um and it's something
I've recovered a lot in the last few
years um by telling myself that indeed
they want me to do that and indeed I
show up so much better to all the
relationships in my life if I've done
some real satisfied with a good day's
work yeah sa you know just that you know
got over that that barrier of resistance
you know the the Steven pressfield thing
of resistance that I wrestled with
resistance and won I think we should all
want people to win and I also um and I
confess I'm going to lose some uh
friends with this but I have variable
latency in terms of my text replies
sometimes it's a day sometimes it's an
hour sometimes a minute sometimes it's a
month I love being on a plane and
scrolling through old text like hey
how's it going missed this and people
like that was a month ago yeah it was
and you know I've been busy you know and
and you know emergencies are dealt with
but it happens what's happening in the
brain and body when we procrastinate oh
um yeah so procrastination is super
interesting there actually some data
that Adam Grant shared with me recently
that people who procrastinate actually
have um tend to be have access to
certain creative stes that non
procrastinators don't because they have
don't start justifying the
procrastination crowd that's a dangerous
line to go yeah procrastination I mean I
mean what the origins of procrastination
are are complicated and varied um to to
really say a single concise statement um
as to what procrastination is but the
way to overcome procrastination is to do
something harder than the hard thing
that you're putting off that's very
clear do something harder don't go clean
your like suddenly people want to do
their their taxes clean their room clean
the garage organize the gym whatever
when they don't want to write a chapter
in their book but you have to pick
something that's worse than writing the
chapter in your book and do that for
five minutes that's the way that the the
dopamine reward system works and some of
these stress systems work um what would
be an example give me give me a tactical
example of this okay I need to write a
chapter on focus and um and tools for
Focus for my book I'm finding I'm doing
everything but doing that let's just set
it kind of a fun example um I'll do
anything but that okay so then you have
to find something worse than that so for
me worse than that is anything involving
a spreadsheet just the idea of a
spreadsheet gives me hives so I would
force myself to do five to 10 minutes of
like like really like establishing a
spreadsheet of my expenses and taxes
related to I don't know some segment of
my work life I mean I can't think of
anything worse in that moment that
doesn't involve physical or
psychological damage so doing that and
then you'll see it will make writing
that book chapter very accessible it's a
down it's a downhill cruise from there
but people find themselves doing all
these things that they would normally
want to put off as a way to avoid doing
the harder things so it's it's about
understanding that what is difficult and
what you want to put off or do is a
dynamic hierarchy I think uh you could
think of it as Dynamic
subordination um you know I don't know
if that's bother borrowed from cosplay
or from uh military or BDSM I I don't
know I heard it some place yeah um but
all places that you M for information
most frequently no it's raccoons and
streets no none of those none of those
communities are communities that I I
know very much about but um I was saying
it factiously but um but the point being
do something harder than the thing
you're trying to avoid now some people
really like deliberate cold exposure for
that reason because you and here I'm
going to really if I've taken heat for
no pun intended for the deliberate cold
exposure thing now I'm really going to
get behind it for the following reason
people who are really into exercise of
various kinds but not deliberate cold
exposure love to push back on people
that do posts about deliberate cold oh
that's not doing anything it's not much
metabolic lift okay but let's really
step back and be honest with ourselves
the adrenaline the the the the pattern
of adrenaline release over time from
deliberate cold exposure is something
that's very hard to recreate safely with
other endeavors you know sure a hard
workout is going to spike your
adrenaline and dopamine also but is it
going to spike it the way that
deliberate cold exposure is no also the
amount of a of a mental barrier that one
has to get over in a moment not there's
no like three warm-up sets like walk on
the treadmill pre-workout show me the
pre-cold plun drink that makes it easier
okay it's
called willpower yeah okay and now some
people come to love deliberate cold
exposure but that's usually for how they
feel afterwards so I think there is so
much utility to deliberate cold exposure
now do people have to do it no but
deliberate cold shower deliberate ice
bath deliberate cold plunge is a is a
world apart from all the other
self-imposed stressors because of the
speed of onset of the stress it's even
even more so than a SAA that's right you
get into a saer and it takes time for
you to heat up it takes time for you to
get uncomfortable I mean it so it's a
very potent tool because of the
amplitude and the timing of adrenaline
that it creates in what else what else
in the uh PR fation dissolving toolkit
so we've got do something that is harder
than the thing that you're trying to get
away from if you can do cold exposure
that's kind of cool if you're like I got
to sit down and do this I find myself
for 10 minutes kind of fluffing about
trying to do stuff I go upstairs I have
a cold shower okay that was way more
miserable than this is going to be if
it's miserable if you like it then no
but if it's way more miserable then
that's the thing to do pick the
miserable thing um I mean sometimes
it'll leave me like hard conversation
you didn't want to have um some people
are you know certain hard conversations
are are harder than others easier than
others but you know in business I've
never had a hard time having hard
convers slaying all sorts of demons in
an attempt to get away from their
procrastination right here one of the
things that I really wanted to talk
about uh was the Peril of over
optimization I think that before we knew
about all of these science-based tools
everyone had an excuse not to be
optimized right and now we're all
educated about this stuff and I think
that a lot of people feel guilt they can
feel guilt because the gap between how
effective they are and how effective
they could be is felt between them so
given that you spend an awful lot of
time thinking about the tools that
people can use how can someone get over
this this guilt of lack of not being
where they should be with getting all of
the things dialed in well guilt is
rarely an effective um emotion although
sometimes guilt and shame can really
help us make significant change um you
know the word optimization and optimize
I think um needs clear definition and
I'm not suggesting that you you are the
one that um said this but a lot of
people think it means being perfect all
the time optimization is something that
we need to look at in the context of the
moment the hour the day the week right
um if you have a viral infection or
you're sick or you're tired or jet
lagged optimization is whatever you can
do to manage the basic five of you know
sunlight sleep nutrition exercise
relationships work productivity that you
can so it's about it's it's a it's a
verb function it's not a state to be in
like floating around
optimized um it's optimization the verb
is a process that we're continually in I
mean people who are raising kids are
exceedingly busy raising kids and
they're trying to optimize raising the
kids and hopefully taking care of their
health as well so I think people see or
hear the long list of science informed
protocols that I talk about and think oh
my goodness how am I supposed to do all
of that that's why I keep coming back to
the basics right look a little bit of
sunlight is better than none a little
bit dimming the lights a little bit is
better than you know keeping them on a
full blast at night um you know making
you know eating a few fewer uh heavily
processed foods they're highly palatable
is better than you know than not doing
that right but um and there are certain
people who have immense amounts of
self-discipline I mean one thing that's
and they're going to do all the things I
mean one thing that's absolutely clear
is that there's a p of people
discovering things that make them feel
much better and then a need to tell
everyone about it and that's that
creates a bit of a divide for people one
thing that I've tried to do is to say
yes I do these tools I do these
protocols but um I'm not just
sympathetic but I you know empathize
with the fact that sometimes things
happen travel kids illness you get into
an argument with a with a significant
other you know or at work or you're just
feeling off you know and so um you know
it's important to try and do these
things on average is my belief and to be
you know gentle with oneself when the
time calls for it and then there's other
times you need to Scruff yourself and
say like enough of this like enough
huberman like it's time to sit down and
write this thing I don't care if you
phone is ringy or not I don't care if
you want to or not and you build up your
amcc while you're doing it right you
know that the if ever there was a carrot
for the hard for doing the hard thing
it's that amcc activation that makes
your amcc larger which makes your
willpower more accessible in the future
so it's not that I'm unsympathetic to
people who are like wow this just feels
like a lot but we also have to remember
um that we should all I think as a
species be individual and indiv as
individual excuse me be striving to do
better each day um better than yesterday
in on the backdrop of what we happen to
be dealing with today I I really really
do I mean last week I had a great week
up until Thursday and then something
happened Thursday was a purely
professional thing and it was like
everything got derailed I literally
didn't sleep that night very rare for me
very rare and I was and it's interesting
the pattern that emerged I did some
reflecting on later after this event
passed which was there's always this
moment where we're like where we don't
want to do damage control where we're
thinking gosh if I just hadn't done that
or if that person just hadn't done that
you you're trying to control the past so
there's that moment and I've learned you
have to let that process take place
unless you have the amazing abilities of
a you know of a special oper tier one
special operations person who seems to
be able to just live in the Moment by
the way those guys I know a lot of them
very close to them tremendous respect
for them but a lot of them have trouble
when they return from that kind of
landscape where well that's done you got
to focus on the next thing because real
life involves sometimes ruminating over
the thing that happened and just living
in that space of I wish that hadn't
happened yeah now you try and compress
that to be a limited amount of time and
then you get to okay damage control and
Damage Control sucks because there's the
opportunity cost of all the other things
that you're not doing while you're doing
damage control so you know the human
animal
including me needs to accept that there
are certain things that we just aren't
going to get perfect um and I hate doing
damage control like everybody does but I
probably hate it a little bit more and
under those conditions I just think okay
you know what this isn't 72 hours lost
this is an opportunity to learn and
indeed we came out of the situation
better had then we not gone into it but
I'll tell you that realization didn't
arrive until Sunday and I was pretty
upset on Friday and I'm not a bad mood
guy I'm not a moody guy die I don't get
headaches I don't get stomach I'm not
moody people don't grade on me even
people with very different opinions and
things I'm like Live and Let Live kind
of like Co my bulog Costello so I guess
to to answer your question very directly
here at the end I
think optimization is not about removing
all negative emotion or physical States
optimization is about working with
what's right in front of you with the
understanding that the human brain and
its capacity to think about the past the
present or the future in some
combination sometimes occasionally the
anchor is is still stuck in the sand a
few hours or days back or years back and
we have to accept that as part of our
normal neural functioning and
psychological functioning and and try
and get um you know and try and get
unmowed and and move forward but that
when we're in those moments you know we
have to know that we're in them and one
of the most useful tools that for this
was given to me by a podcast guest the
episode hasn't come out yet Dr Lisa
Feldman Barrett who's done a lot on the
neurobiology of emotions and ology of
emotions and you know she said and it so
powerful anytime you feel a high
activation state of any kind you should
stop because what it's what's happening
is it's revealing to you something very
important and if you don't stop to think
about why I'm so upset or why I'm so
happy you're going to miss an important
lesson so this could be positive states
too anytime you feel like you're getting
above eight out of 10 or seven and a
half out of 10 on some scale of internal
arousal for good or or bad reasons you
want to
reflect what is the lesson do gosh I
really love this person I love this
interaction I love this aspect of my job
so that's going to inform the next job I
take because I don't love the rest of
the job or this really sucks and there's
a lesson and I learned a very important
lesson in that last Thursday but I
didn't realize it until late Saturday
but I remember on Thursday this thing
hit and I was pissed I don't get pissed
very often but I was pissed and I
remember hearing Lisa's voice in my head
and thinking okay what is this revealing
to me Strategic Learning opportunity
three days later I had in my journal and
I still have in my journal I have a many
journals but I have one that's permanent
that kind of is the distilled out things
that kind of rise to the top as truths
for me and it revealed to me that I care
oh so very much about certain things to
the point where they're not about my
career they're really about my my life
my quality of life and that small
cluster of things is something that now
I protect inside I'm stealing Paul K's
language here but inside the castle
walls of what I consider important like
I brought some things in that I think
before I wasn't Reckless with but I
didn't realize it would be like if you
have a prized horse or child and you're
letting them play outside the castle
walls and you know they're Marauders out
there but all of a sudden one takes a a
a you know an arrow through the heart
and you're like and it's a huge loss
well what do you do with your other
horses or children you bring them inside
the castle walls right but you it would
be a shame to have to have that
experience in order to recognize how
important they are to you but there were
certain things that I was just not
protecting and now I feel so secure I
also feel like I gained a huge lesson so
do so the the short list here is when it
when the [__] storm hits to put it in
scientific
nomenclature know that
you you're going to be focused on this
for a while accept that as quickly as
you can but understand that accepting
that itself is its own hard process
B pay attention to those states of high
arousal there are lessons there even if
this is good stuff even if this is great
stuff the love of your life you're now
getting engaged there's lessons that
there's things to be gleaned that you'll
want to go back to later and then three
or four days later go back to those
things and examine them from some
different perspectives because I think
there huge lessons in these high arousal
States whether or not it's high arousal
because of terrible things or high
arousal because of good things and I
think having a process for moving
through that is something I didn't have
and I'm still learning to cultivate and
you know Jos if you wish that you hadn't
spent as much time on the phone or other
people's wish they haven't spent as much
time on the phone I wish I had known a
or had a process for dealing with things
that happened to me or that I created um
that were unfortunate for myself or
others they created for me a process of
moving through that that semi structure
that accepts that you're giving up some
degree of control but that there's the
opportunity to regain control and
establish lessons that you never ever
would be able to access purely
retroactively
yeah that's kind of like Alchemy like
taking something which is you know
objectively a pretty crap situation and
turning it into something which is
really really useful there was a a quote
that stuck with me that you tweeted last
year or maybe you just taught it to me I
can't remember advice I got early in my
career don't over engage in any
controversy unless you are willing to
stake your entire reputation on it
rather keep focused on discovering new
things and creating or else you become
known for the controversy and nothing
else that is no going back right yeah
this um isn't about avoiding being
cancelled uh because I think some people
might translate it to mean that which is
why I say it's not about that it's about
you know we're given this enormous um
privilege to communicate our thoughts
very fast now through social media and
whether or not you have a big following
small following or no following it is
still a privilege and it's something
that I've learned to really think
through and guard and protect as an
asset set right that we have and I've
I've thought about this from the
beginning of posting on things online um
and set up certain rules for myself uh
for instance I try to ensure that 90% of
my posts are really for the pure benefit
of the the audience and not for my own
entertainment occasionally I'll see
something and I'll have a one of these
like you know I'll see something animal
post or something like oh that's so cool
or the other day I saw something on a on
an X account
about you know bumblebees that sleep
inside of flowers and it was really cool
about how they look at polarized light
and stuff but I just was really tickled
by this fact I thought other people
might be as well but it was more for my
own entertainment frankly but 90% of
what I put out there I'm really trying
to think will people benefit from this
will they learn from it not are they
going to be interested in it but are are
they going to learn from it will it get
them thinking or doing something
beneficial to their mental health or
physical health Lord knows I've been
attacked for you know saying hey this is
an interesting study about deliberate
cold Expos Ure and then people are like
oh it's underpowered and you know it's a
marginal effect and you know and I love
this because I come from the field of
science it's sort of funny a turn people
loose on a paper where because you know
you're going to get a range of opinions
because no two people read the same
paper the same way and everyone would
like to say that they are the Arbiter of
truth and how to read papers which just
makes me chuckle normally those people
have not published very many papers
themselves it's sort of this inverse
relationship but nonetheless I like to
put things out there that stimulate
thinking uh positive thinking I don't
like controversy for sake of controversy
but you and I have colleagues in the
podcast space and there are many people
in who are public facing who see a
current event and they just say what
they think and you know what more power
to them but it is and I will say it is a
distractor from a larger message that
they likely have if they have one at all
but and and you see this and it's not
that they go down what happens is they
they take their audience that has been
built around a certain set of topics
iics and suddenly they're talking about
current events I guess what I'm
basically saying is I don't talk about
current events yeah you've never as far
as I'm aware you've never commented on
politics you've never made any no I
actually this is I've um politics came
to around to me in an interesting way
I'll just share this because it's it's
exactly how it happened Rogan had Robert
Kennedy Jr on his podcast okay and I um
liked the post and I commented and the
comment was the following I said I hope
all um I I hope all presidential
candidates uh go on long form podcast
because I happen to believe that it's a
great way to get to know candidates
plural [__] no so didn't someone edit
your Wikipedia page okay so in this so
this is interesting so I got calls from
colleagues of mine at
Stanford I got L literally calls and
texts I got calls from major media
Outlets asking whether or not I'm an RFK
supporter antivaxer to which I said I
don't know how you concluded that okay
that's certainly not my stance right my
politics are my politics but but there
was a huge leap from and I said and I in
my comment I said you know I I look
forward to listening and I hope all the
candidates go on long form podcast I
also see Robert in the gym and it always
looks like he's training hard he trains
hard he's in good condition yeah he
wears jeans which I don't understand
when he trains but anyway but he trains
hard odd Choice odd choice but it free
free country so so so be it so was I
commenting on the content of the of his
podcast no was I commenting on you prob
hadn't even listened to it yet I hadn't
listened to it yet so but was
interesting was in the subsequent days I
got an onslaught of kind of assumptions
or presumptions really what they were
and then yes my I mean this isn't about
maybe this is the time I I published
over 70 peer-reviewed articles that are
indexed on PubMed um you know many of
which had secondary sources in time and
and other major Outlets that covered the
the findings for the relevance to the
general public at the time this is
around 2016 mostly but in the subsequent
years as well that was scraped from my
Wikipedia scraped from Wikipedia you
mean like scrub removed from well my
research contributions are not there on
Wikipedia any Still Still and um and
then it was there were assertions that I
was an antivaxer there were assertions
that um that I was supporting certain uh
political agendas and and so on and then
the the page was locked by the editorial
staff I've had Communications with the
founders of Wikipedia who the page has
been adjusted somewhat um but not none
of my research has been put back I I
actually at this point I I think it's
sort of interesting because it's such
it's more actually it's kind of
fortunate that it happened in the sense
that it's more telling about how the
kind of editorializing around Wikipedia
exists then this is really not about me
I'm I'm telling this this anecdote um as
a way to sort of reveal what was my
experience makes very clear that um you
know now it includes some some positives
some negatives about the podcast that's
fine we we cover supplements some people
are and promote supplements in certain
context mostly behavioral tools but
supplements too and so I'm perfectly
fine with that being included because
that's true um but it was very
interesting to see how um when I the the
way that sort of people will pick up the
ball and run with things and um and it's
and it's it's been super useful for me
to understand this because what allowed
me to do at first it was like Hey like
what's this about then I tried to figure
it out then I went you know straight to
the top in terms of trying to understand
and I realized it's like okay what do I
really love doing I love forging for
information that can benefit people's
mental health and physical health I love
organizing that information I love
dispersing that information to the best
of my abilities and um and those are the
things that make me happy and those are
the things that um seem to resonate with
a certain number of people those are
also some of the same things that seem
to irritate a certain number of people
and and I love doing it and so what I'm
going to do is just return to doing that
and I learned a lot about the landscape
of online information in the process
very formative experience it seems very
formative and as an academic you know
all the my papers are on PubMed there's
no unless the paper is retracted or
corrected there's no removing things
from the library Google Scholar will
just be kind of Lo like no one's going
in there my H index is fixed and it's
not to be very clear I want to be very
clear uh because I don't want to
contradict the the very thing that I
opened up the question which is this is
not this is not something I wanted to
like die on The Sword of right but it it
it really alerted me to the fact that so
much of the information that's on the on
the internet um has been massaged in a
particular direction based on
presumptions so one of the reasons I'm
taking this opportunity to talk about
this is not to counter major Media news
outlets they're just trying to make a
living for it's kind of interesting they
have a lot of the same advertisers that
my podcast does you know I don't
advertise fendy bags but um but you know
they use adver iers we we use them it
makes it free to everybody um as a
consequence but I think that it's really
important for people to realize that
this question of like what can we who
can we trust what can we trust we all
have to learn to be good scientists and
foragers of information and and and the
macro for me is that hopefully people
are learning to forge for information
better as a consequence of understanding
that like yeah no one person holds the
truth this is not Mount Olympus right so
I think the interesting thing one of the
reasons why might have seen an outsized
response to this is people aren't used
to you being in anything right like the
the the biggest conspiracy that Andrew
hubman is going to be a part of is like
some new study on sunlight in the eyes
or something it's like is there where's
the P value and stuff it's like it's
it's like it's not uh accessible to the
nor plunge Mafia precisely yeah there is
by the way a cold plunge Mafia who are
they yeah well I'm I'm not going to talk
about it's like a what's it called the
Saros you got the Brotherhood you've
made a blood I probably shouldn't have
said that you can keep it in but it's
it's a pretty it's it's a strong group
let's just say politically socially
financially very powerful I understand
why people are nervous about the cold
plunge it's me too
so lots and lots of people
online
um get known for their expertise within
one area and then start to think to
themselves
well why why shouldn't the world know
about my opinion on the Ukraine conflict
like I've got lots of things to say and
everybody thinks that it's very very
valuable so maybe I should contribute to
what we should do about climate change
or what we what we think should happen
in the next election and I think that
you know to your credit you've done a
really good job because you will have
opinions you've just chosen not to share
them presumably right and I vote yeah so
but you've chosen not to do that and I
think that it's almost like uh the
sensitivity dial was turned up so much
it's like where's the first ever so we
knew we knew it was the tattoos and the
beard we always knew that that guy was
like a like an RFK or you know what I
mean and any opportunity for somebody to
jump on this right so this is something
that I've been kind of noticing in
myself somebody asked me this I'm doing
these live shows at the moment Soo I
know that you do live shows great I want
to come to one of your live shows we
we're not doing La I'll find you a date
live shows are so different than podcast
and I I learned I can't wait what is
your uh State before you step on stage
oh I mean I have a whole pro set of
protocols we can talk about would would
you send me them sure yeah I would love
I spend the whole day basically in a
rhythm and I talk to only a limited
number of people and I've got a rhythm
in my head and I'm I'm in uh nsdr
hypnosis part of the day I send and
receive a few texts of Rick my friend
Tim Armstrong my friend Jim Theo I touch
base with my team I do prayer I'm I'm
like I'm an an altered state and I need
all the help looking forward I'm looking
forward to the protocol I've got my tour
my first UK and Island Tour is happening
in November and then I'm going to Dubai
we've got a huge 2,000 person show in
Dubai then we're going to do uh Canada
in the US anyway um I got asked recently
I'm doing work in progress shows like a
comedian for these so I'm doing 40
person shows at East Austin comedy club
all of the profits go to charity I
wanted to work out my material right
before I went on stage even though it's
not it's not comedy stuff um but I
wanted to to do it and it's been really
really useful because I've been able to
watch I shouldn't really open with that
story it's not so we can move that a bit
later it's a bit heavy it's a whatever
whatever I got a lot of thoughts about
this yeah um
so somebody asked me at one of these
shows what some of the Unseen prices are
that you pay for um building a platform
of this size and what I realized
was both you and I just like doing the
shows that we do like I love I there is
nothing that I would prefer to do at
4:23 p.m. on a Friday afternoon than sit
down and have this conversation there is
nothing that I would rather do right and
if you do that for long enough you end
up accumulating the size of an audience
that carries with it responsibility that
you didn't ask for I didn't ask to have
my like and comment on my friend Joe's
Instagram post scrutinized by mainstream
media and trended across of Twitter
not only that I had colleagues calling
the saying not what is happening to you
but literally what happened to you right
isn't that awesome but the same week
that we published a clinical trial so it
was not as if like my scientific career
so it was pretty interesting I actually
had very fruitful conversations with
those people I I know what I I
eventually figured out what the uh
answer is to the the question you asked
before um which is still in in this vein
which is here here's the
thing there's a certain seg segment in
fact a very large segment of
listenership viewership and
media that want to see you and me and
other people do what they would do in a
given circumstance for instance why
didn't you counter soand so when they
said blank yep why didn't you stand up
for this group when you had the
opportunity on that situation what
they're basically saying is they wish
they had had the opportunity and they're
angry that you're
not tip of the spear for them in
circumstances that they don't have
access to y i get it but one one thing
that uh I learned early on by
observation is that a sense of justice
and a sense of strong opinion about
certain things is incredibly important I
mean that that runs in my family but you
have to know when Justice needs to line
up with action or when Justice is time
to walk away yeah when you're not the
best suited for something the other
thing that and I have to say Joe Rogan
is the best at what I'm about to
describe and I admire it so much first
of all I'll go on record saying that I
think Joe Rogan has been clearly net
positive for science bringing about lots
of different
conversations about tons of topics let's
just leave the vaccine thing aside for
the moment but sleep the the the
cosmos anmy right um Peter AA and and on
okay it's very clear whether or not he's
aware of it or not that he's not going
to be leveraged by anybody no one's
going to come on to show he he can't he
doesn't allow himself to be used right
so when someone gets upset that you're
not taking a stand that they would take
they're upset that they can't use you to
reach their ends and you know I have
many flaws like anybody but maybe a few
extra I really do and um but one but but
included in that extensive list of flaws
is not the capacity to be used it just
is not I have strong opinions and
there's time for justice and action
along particular lines and I prefer to
do that not using my social media
platform or podcast platform in part
because there's a tremendous number of
things that I want to learn about and
teach about guests I want to have on to
educate as many people as possible so
I'm not being political or diplomatic
I'm being extremely strategic I'm saying
I'm not going to be use to achieve
somebody else's end I want that's
basically what it is and so I'm I think
very hard about like the things I want
to take on and they're mostly about
helping people regulate circadian rhythm
stress sleep Eating Disorders depression
understanding of self through a mental
health series addiction sleep you know I
said sleep multiple times um and on and
on and the other stuff is really barbed
wire you can get snagged on it and stuck
there and then you're tossed up against
the barbed wire and you're fighting and
you're bleeding out and guess what a
bunch of really great stuff is happening
so that you could be focusing on I often
I always that's really what it is I
always think about how much of some of
the smartest minds of our generation's
time has been taken up arguing
over pick your topical issue headline of
the moment like what what else could
have been achieved if these people
who outside of the uh myopia and and
like catastrophe that is most of Pop
Culture headline stuff are phenomenal
thinkers and yet they have
a it's like their cryptonite that
there's something that pulls them away
and I want I want to rip them back in
when my thumbs start buzzing you know
there's the premotor circuits that get
me wanting to put something how often do
you how often do you um uh type and
delete does that happen much three times
a day you're kidding no but not because
of political reasons but um or
sensitivity issues but um yeah about
three times a day there are a lot of
posts that just don't go up because like
it's not going to land right I don't
touch on current events I mean our
friend Lex Friedman covers a lot of
current events um and gets right in the
middle I mean he likes to he'll travel
to current events yeah you know he'll
land himself in in in dangerous
territories I think also something
that's really helped me I had great
scientific advisers and mentors coming
up I also I keep I understand the limits
of having one brain and one personality
and one history and I have a council of
people that I refer to often it's funny
I brought my notebook today which I'm
always carrying around one of these
little notebooks I'm writing on cards
and things and in the front of this
notebook is a list of names I didn't
think we'd get into this at all today
but you a list of names of people that I
I look at this list is that the Council
of hberman right there it is who's in
the well I'm not I'll give you a
non-exhaustive but accurate list I mean
it includes Rick Rubin close friend
Peter AA close
friend it includes Joe Strummer Oliver
Sachs both of whom are dead and who I
never met but I've consumed their
writings and I know people close to them
and I have stories about them it's got a
couple people whose names I'm not going
to disclose
um there there are a few others here
that maybe my dead advisers all three of
them my dog Costello had a he couldn't
be he he was so stubborn you could not
get him to do something he didn't want
to do it was like he would he you
couldn't move him and he always was
right about the things he didn't want to
do he had an incredible sense of of
understanding about his his environment
uh my sister's on here and then you know
my team who isn't aren't just my team
but Rob Mike Ian Chris Martin Gary Greg
like Sarah they're they're here right so
these are like anytime I'm going to put
something into the world I look at this
list and I think like okay I don't need
uh unanimity but like what would they
say about this and because I don't need
to text them most times nine times out
of 10 I know infer it just by knowing
them absolutely this is this is
something I really I really wanted to
kind of touch on because you've gone and
there are others on that list so for
those that I didn't include it's like a
um I want to be Jim feeo right um yeah
Joe's on here you know it's like you're
doing an awards ceremony yeah Lex is on
here I mean you know so I mean it's just
so clear to me that my brain can't do it
right all the time and I need to call on
people alive and dead like known and
that I haven't known to to help me and
you know it feels sort of corny to talk
about but if there's one thing I tried
to do with the podcast it's to normalize
some of the conversations around things
like anxi stress Sexual Health we've
been doing a lot about hormone sexual
health for women and men communication
um you know normalize some of the
discussion around these practices that
that to some people might seem kind of
hokey but to me I mean this list isn't
like three out of 10 in terms of the
potency scale of like my productivity
and feelings of of safety in life so
that I can go do my best work it's like
11 out of 10 yeah 11 out of 10 um and
it's the kind of thing where most of
these people don't even know that no one
knows they're on their list until on
this list until now um but I've always
had this list in different forms and
it's updated over the years when I was a
kid I mean growing up I a hero listen to
him every day of my life from 13 on Tim
Armstrong lead singer for rans Operation
Ivy transplants you like literally every
day and through some magical Stroke of
Luck we become very close friends so he
was guiding me all along but he's about
he's 10 years older than I am
he has deep he's extremely smart
extremely smart and he has deep
understanding of human dynamics and how
to be in the world while trying to do
creative work now he's a musician not a
scientist but his level of curiosity
intellect memory I mean it's it like it
doesn't just it for years it inspired me
but now like I'll text or call him I did
that last week like hey this is a tough
situation really helped me I called a
few other people too but he's on this
list and he hasn't been since I was 13
how Wild is that it turns out you know
never meet your Heroes right well it
turns out this hero ended up like wildly
exceeding my expectations in the
positive direction you do know that
there's someone listening to this
there's probably millions of people
listening to this at least not
thousands to whom you're that person
right that you they have this parasocial
relationship with you even if you didn't
ask for it even social I like that it's
almost like Paranormal but parasocial
that's the time write that down get it
in there along with whatever it was
cosplay and we got a good list and Huber
husbands Huber daddies
um I'm really fascinated by what's what
it's been like to be a relatively
unknown academic working in the annals
just doing your thing doing your
research to now as a byproduct of a
passion to share science-based tools for
people now being sort of Thrust out into
the public what's the felt sense of this
rapid increase in exposure and scrutiny
and fame being like
um so i' love to tell you that it's
disorienting but um truly by virtue of
feeling very aligned with the work and
purpose of the work that I'm doing I
feel like I'm at least in terms of my
daily activities and where my mind is at
I'm exactly where I for the first time
I'm like exactly where I I feel like I'm
exactly where I belong not because I'm
known and that the podcast has achieved
this uh recognition for which I'm very
grateful and humbled by but because I
love foraging for organizing and
dispensing information so 95% of my
cognitive powers are set toward like the
episode I'm preparing for next week or
the week after and I have to like
literally pull in my impulse to now take
off on a tangent about my use of toe
spacers to fix this like imbalance
because of like foot health and like
I'll I'll go there that's the thing but
like it's all getting teed up I I
prepare for podcast I someone asked how
long it takes me and I realized in total
because I start so many months ahead
somewhere between very low end the
lowest ever would have been 12 but it's
typically more like 150 to two hours of
preparation and I love every freaking
second of it and so for me it feels
great because it allows me to do what
I'm doing now in terms of being public
facing I mean I'm a pretty introverted
person I love close Dynamics you know if
I think for a second about meaning
one-on-one Dynamics and small group
dynamics small parties at my house and
things I'm comfortable in crowds but I'm
not interested in in being in them per
se but if I think for a second about how
many people are going to listen to
something I'll just I don't know I don't
think about it because best not to do it
um you know it's changed my life
dramatically and and mostly for the
positive um in positive ways you know
getting filmed while you're in the gym
is um funny because you know I always
like If Ever I need to use perfect form
like now
I'm guy on the that's the real that's
the real Scandal it's not that you liked
a Joe and RFK post it's the fact that
you can't do preacher kills with perfect
temper I'm full I'm a full range emotion
guy I'm a full range emotion guy um but
I am the guy on The Tib machine every
day um not every day but any day I'm in
the gym um yeah getting filmed when
you're not aware that you're getting
filmed some security breaches in that it
not directly towards me but towards
members of my family and community that
those have been annoying but that goes
with the territory going to been mostly
lucky 99% of interactions are immensely
positive when people come over and say
hello I I enjoy it it's you know I don't
always have a lot of time so there those
kinds of things but I'm somebody who's
genuinely curious about other people so
in those interactions like I want to
learn about them um I already know about
me I want to learn about them yeah I
I've always been genuinely curious about
other people this isn't a line like I
I've been friends with the garbage man
the janitor the um you know my dentist
like you you know well there I've got
stuff in my mouth so I can't it's a
one-way conversation but um you know
learning about people I think allows one
to also deliver information in a way
that's more accessible to people this is
something that I'm I would guess I would
go as far as to say that the level of
Fame and recognition that I have now is
about as like goldilock Zone as it's as
it's possible to get it's maybe once
every 10 to 15 minutes if I'm walking in
a crowded area somewhere and it'll be a
10-minute convers a 10-second
conversation of hi mate really love the
podcast that oh like the Amazon Prime
delivery driver shouted out of the
window the day and those are the people
that that that allow us to do what we do
right like like I'm so grateful that
people are interested in the kinds of
information that you put out and that I
put out I mean I look at them I I look
at anyone I interact with as the
students in my classroom the same way I
would the way I manage my comment
section on social media classroom rules
you can say whatever you want to me but
don't be don't be uncool to other people
and or I'm going to block you why it's
not like I can't take it listen I grew
up in skateboarding I grew up in
Academia The Hazing process in those
communities very different was intense
it was physical psychological emotional
torture at times and so you develop a
very thick skin I mean skateboarding if
you do something and you don't make it
look right or something's a little off
like you're going to own that reputation
for years and so that's your new
nickname yeah you you have to have your
I I'm not going to say it the way I'd
say it back then but like I mean you
have to
have every your kit has to be right
everything has to be right and yet you
have to try things and so it's you know
learning to work through the narrow
constraints of of social media is
nothing compared to trying to come up
through Academia where people say oh
nice nice great to see you and then they
kill your papers or grants behind your
back it's a game of backstabbing now
they put reviewers on on names on paper
so it conditioned me for it I will say
this I'm very grateful that all this
happened in my 40s my mid-40s I started
the podcast when I was 45 I'm 48 now
it's been 3 years why why that timing I
just think about the young brain the 20s
30s you know so much of of our identity
has formed earlier in life but we're
still trying to figure out who we are I
know exactly who I am I'm the guy that
since age five has been Gathering
organizing and disseminating information
I like lots of different kinds of people
I like Misfits and runts and winner and
like and you know and punkers and
hippies and I have gay friends and
straight friends like Live and Let Live
I love it all that's why I oriented
towards skateboarding and punk rock
because it was like all the Styles all
the hair styles I mean people think of
like just like bullet belts and Mohawks
no then you got your peace punks you
your vegan punks you got all this like
and I have my thing what I liked but I
love the variety because I love the
Flora and Fauna of life I don't love
raccoons or cppy bars per se but I love
how they fit into the animal kingdom and
I I have an obsession with animals and
weird animals and seapods and the
octopuses and the you know uh the plat
pusses and and all of it and so for me
like being on social media I get to step
back and look at all of it but I'm not
going to let anyone decide who I am or
who I'm not like I'm the guy who was
wearing black shirts before my colleague
David felon will tell you this he's a
professor at e sand Cruz he once tweeted
he was like he always wore the black
shirt and I was like yes it's true I
didn't change it all I didn't feel like
I had to modify myself I know you know I
always tried hold the door for people I
I I tried am I perfect no um so it's
changed things a lot um and yet it
hasn't changed me at
all I love it Dr Andre hubman ladies and
gentlemen dude I really appreciate you
very much appreciate the support you've
given me over the last year when I've
needed to text you when I've needed a
little bits in pieces it really does
mean a lot to me so what can people
expect remainder of 2023 what have you
got coming up okay well I can tell you
um but first can can I just please just
take a moment say thank you um for this
opportunity thanks for the kind words I
will say something very important about
you which is that you know coming up in
the various Sports I did skateboarding
and science I have a really good eye for
the the person like I'm gonna put my
money on that person to be at the top at
some point down the line it's
interesting because um I'm not talented
at many things I'm efficient at certain
things I work really hard truly um if I
have any inborn abilities it's my memory
is always been sharp but loving the
thing you're learning
helps early on when I saw your content
it created some sense in Me based on how
you were delivering it the passion the
honesty behind it and the ways in which
you were like moving through and trying
to figure it out that I was like this
guy's going to be like at the top and
I I was I was right in that your Ascent
trajectory predicts that like I I mean
okay there's still room for Upward
trajectory great but you know every once
in a while someone comes along where
like he just loves what he does it's so
clear that he's meant to do this like
you love and I think it has a lot to do
with the genuiness with which you invite
on and meet your guests like you're not
going to put someone on because they're
going to get clicks you're you're going
to invite people on because you really
want to talk to them and that that's
very clear and I think I know that
resonates with people so I've been truly
an avid consumer of your content from go
and it's been awesome to see your ascent
and I'm sure that this is just the
beginning so I want to say thank you
thank you you know thank you and and I I
look forward to deepening our friendship
um and that's a real thing because early
on when Lex and I became friends through
podcasting at some point I realized I
was like we need to hang out without
these microphones in front of us I went
out to Austin for two weeks we just hung
out just hung out it's also where he did
the Jiu-Jitsu thing thing where he
choked so got me there I'll get you back
Lex but not with jiu-jitsu psychological
Jiu-Jitsu but I hope we get the chance
to spend time and I really just want to
say what whatever you're doing keep
going because it's awesome and it's
clear that you're really working hard in
your craft and I'm really excited about
the lives and we can talk about that
thank you rest of 2023 I'm going to try
and finish this book that I've been
procrastinating on for a few years now
it's mainly going to be a book of
protocols so it's very straight forward
as to what to do it's kind of the what
to do stuff not so much story I think
there's a need for that so you know
that's going to that's going to break
the world when that thing comes out well
I'm putting my heart and soul into it I
got you got an idea of completion date
and then publication pralees should
probably be February and and it should
come out end of 24 y so and I'm putting
everything I've got into that book um
while still podcasting we're going to do
a series we've done these guest series
we did one with Dr Andy Galpin on
Fitness we did one on mental Health with
Dr Paul Conti we're going to do one with
Dr Matthew Walker on sleep and one with
Dr Anna lmy on addiction and dopamine
soon so that the guest series um are are
that going forward and then you know
there were times when we thought okay we
need to do something else like do we
need an app do we need and we've really
taken a step back and we're just like
we're just going to keep searching for
it organizing and dispensing information
mainly in the form of the Monday podcast
occasion of these guest series we do
have a premium channel that generates
Revenue that is directed towards
scientific studies I Haven talk too much
about this but a significant portion of
that has been put to philanthropy to
Laboratories working on eating disorders
on Mind Body States on intermittent
fasting didn't you didn't you recently
uh redo your website is your searchable
so if you go to hubman lab.com the
engineers have done a great job where
it's highly searchable now it take you
to specific timestamps you could even
say like dopamine procrastination it'll
take you to that particular time stamp
and I think as the AI tools get better
um there'll be more more things like
that but really it's going to just be
more of the same live shows any more
live shows this year we got live shows
coming up in Australia so the first one
in Sydney sold out the opera house one
sold out but there's another one being
announced soon and then there's a
Melbourne and Brisbane where should
people go if they want to sign up for
that it's hubman lab.com
tour to get tickets oh yeah um and those
are fun and they're very different than
the podcast and but you know I'm not I
joked a a few months back with uh
traditional media I wasn't joking that
you know I might run for office someday
like from what I've seen of the
experience of politics like I want to
retract that statement I have zero minus
one interest in running for office um
but I have every interest in just
continuing to to indulge this this
Obsession slash uh Delight that I get
from learning and teaching and and
sharing information so like yeah that's
the plan and um keep the main thing the
main thing man yeah that's the thing you
know and I never know like I come from a
long line of academic advis ERS that all
died early like I hope I'll live a long
time but I don't know if it's going to
be a cancer or bullet or a boss that's
going to take me out or old age I have
no idea so I'm just you know I'm just
leaning into this as hard as I can hell
yeah I appreciate you man thank you for
today I appreciate you thanks so much
Chris thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode with Dr
huberman you will love my episode with
Dr Peter AA which you can check out
right
here go on press
it